So, Nachet,
Wer ist heute montags am Start?
Gib zu, ziemlich
unpraktische Zeit zum Streamson.
Montag 13.19 Uhr.
Der Feuer ist wie immer
am Start. Du bist auch immer da, oder?
Immer instant
am Start.
Habt ihr noch Urlaub?
Oder müsst ihr heute arbeiten? Seid ihr vielleicht gerade
auf der Arbeit? Also ich muss morgen wieder arbeiten.
Beste Zeit für Stream.
Schmoll Access Point
am Start.
Da sind sie ja alle hier
Was ist denn?
Geht ja direkt los
Ich hätte gar nicht gedacht, dass so viele direkt am Start sind
13 Uhr
Massive
Na gut, wie viel ist mehr?
Werden wir mal gucken, weil die Zeit ist wirklich sehr ungünstig
Für die meisten Leute, glaube ich
Deswegen, ich habe mir überlegt
Ich, ähm
Also ich hatte zwei Sachen, die ich machen wollte
Einmal wollte ich gucken, wie man in Rust
Schönes DLI-Anwendungen macht
Habe ich noch ein paar Libraries gefunden.
Mal gucken, ob was da so von taugt.
Und das zweite war, ich wollte noch
bei CacheOS die anderen Desktops ausprobieren.
Aber dann habe ich mir gedacht,
das mache ich mal irgendwann abends,
wenn mehr Leute zugucken können.
Gerade Mittagspause.
Excellent.
Ich habe auch gerade Mittagspause gemacht.
Also ich meine, ich habe heute frei.
Aber ich habe auch Mittagspause gemacht.
Ich habe richtig massive Pepo-Fett.
gefuttert
rust sieht auch also gerade rust was viele rust features verwendet und wo du
rust so ein bisschen geilen musst was lifetimes angeht was was trades angeht
was wie wo implementiert sein muss das kann schon sehr hässlich aussehen da
Da gebe ich dir recht.
Das ist aber halt anders als bei C++.
Bei C++ gibt es da keinen Grund dafür, dass es hässlich sein muss.
Außer, dass das C++-Gremium seit, frag mich nicht, 15 Jahren komische Dinger macht.
Bei Rust ist es so, Rust braucht diese Dinger, damit es Compile-Time-Validation halt machen kann von deinem Code.
Also sonst wäre Rust nicht Rust.
Und es hat zumindest noch gewisse innere Logik dahinter.
Ritz-Col wieder am Start.
By the way, hab nachdem ich dein Setup auf Sway in VMware versucht zu können, noch das Clipboard gefixt.
Äh, was?
Sway hatte doch Probleme, da gingen doch die Terminals auch nicht auf.
Ach Moment, VMware Clipboard geht nicht, oder was?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Man kann da nicht rauskopieren
Das muss ich mal kurz checken
Ist das kaputt?
Alter
Meine Güte, gibt es irgendwas, was da ordentlich
funktioniert und nicht nur 80-90%
Das ist halt schrecklich, Alter
Oh ne
Na gut, laden wir LTS-Körnel.
Wayland von Super, dann müssen wir mal gucken, wie super das jetzt funktioniert.
Ich probiere das gerade mal aus mit dem Kopieren aus der VM.
Mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Bin ich mal gespannt.
Dass es grundsätzlich innerhalb der Umgebung geht, ja.
Aber ob ich rein und raus kopieren kann aus der VM ist die Frage.
Das war ja schon unter X manchmal ein bisschen schwierig.
Da muss man die richtigen Pakete installieren.
Mr. AK schreibt, wenn ich noch nicht mal den IHK-Antrag abgeben konnte,
muss ich mir dann vom Chef stressen lassen, dass ich mal langsam komplett dokufertig sein soll.
Nö.
Warum sollte die Doku fertig sein, bevor dein Projekt überhaupt akzeptiert ist?
Also, es schadet sicherlich nichts, im Vorfeld schon anzufangen, ja.
aber das komplett hübsch und und fertig und und komplett erstellt zu haben macht ja vor
projektannahme eigentlich überhaupt keinen sinn weil im zweifelsfall sagte iak das projekt gefällt
uns nicht ist es ist recht selten da kannst du ja noch mal ein bisschen anpassen im großen und
ganzen wird es dann trotzdem auch was ähnliches rauslaufen aber das macht ja eigentlich vor der
Projektabgabe, also vor der
Annahme des Antrags, macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Okay, so.
Jetzt schauen wir mal kurz, ob das funzt.
Wir könnten heute auch
unter KDE programmieren.
Naja, das machen wir nicht.
Da habe ich eigentlich keinen Bock drauf.
Ich will meine gewohnte Umgebung verwenden.
Okay, probieren wir das doch mal.
Also, machen wir das hier mal auf.
Kek, kek, kek, kek.
Copy-Paste. Geht das?
Nö.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Sekunde.
Vom Host in die
VM kopieren geht?
Aber von der VM
zum Host zurück geht nicht.
Das ist aber echt dumm.
Das ist aber echt.
Und das Sway geht auch nicht von Host
zu VM. Soll ich es mal ausprobieren?
Moment.
Wie loggt man sich hier aus?
Session. Logout.
Logout.
Sway.
Haben wir das hier am Start?
Schau doch in den VM Settings.
Was soll ich da gucken?
Ob es aktiviert ist?
Ja, aktiviert ist das schon.
Wo muss man da gucken?
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass man das deaktivieren kann überhaupt.
Hier, enable, copy, paste.
Das ist alles aktiviert.
Das liegt aber an Wayland, wenn das rumschpackt.
So, hier haben wir jetzt was.
So, Kitty und so hat er hier nicht richtig funktioniert.
Und das Way, deswegen werde ich das nicht verwenden.
Also ich will nicht Kitty verwenden, ich will Westterm verwenden.
Gucken wir mal, ob das theoretisch funktioniert.
Warum habe ich denn eigentlich
ein englisches
Tastatur-Layout?
Irgendwas, Paru ist dabei.
Oder was?
Ich bohre nochmal Paru.
West Term.
Sind die Services auch aktiviert?
nicht nur die packages installieren ja anscheinend ja ich habe das nicht eingerichtet ist es
standardmäßig sofort konfiguriert wir kommen western western funktioniert prinzipiell natürlich
natürlich stimmt okay kopieren wir mal hier irgendwas so was haben was kopiert schau mal
geht net und das rein kopieren und so ok und das way funktioniert beides net geil
exzellent ja dann wird es wahrscheinlich nichts mit heiling window manager und
weiland hyperland tut ja auch schon mal gar nicht richtig bleibt ja wirklich nur
das. Wir können doch mal gucken, ob alles
aktiviert ist.
Von Swesterm
hier. Gescheit.
Ja.
Top. Oh, Wobbly Windows.
Ich habe eigentlich fast schon wieder Bock,
was anderes als einen Tiling Window Manager
zu verwenden, weil ich Wobbly Windows habe.
Das gucke ich mir
gleich an.
So.
Warte mal.
Was wollte ich jetzt gerade gucken?
Vmware.
Vmware User.
Müssen wir aktivieren.
Habe ich.
Okay.
Schauen wir mal.
Geht nicht.
Was man früher noch installieren musste,
war
GTK MM oder irgendwie sowas.
Wie hieß das denn?
Hier.
GTK MM.
Wie hieß das?
Das musste man früher installieren.
glaube ich gtk mm muss man vorher ins früher installieren damit vor allem copy
paste ordentlich funktioniert ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher welches wir
installieren jetzt einfach 1 2 3 4 5
Gucken wir mal ob das vielleicht daran liegt.
WL Clipboard installieren.
Ja, gucken wir mal gleich.
Installiere ich alles.
Yes.
Wow.
Paru.
Ich habe Paru noch nie verwendet.
Ich benutze Yay normalerweise.
Aber ich accepte das als einfach mal.
Wir sind einfach sidetracked.
Hat das mit Rust gar nichts zu tun, aber muss auch mal geguckt werden.
Compiler-Stells.
Erstmal gleich wieder Scheihulut eingefangen oder irgendwas.
Wer weiß, was da alles jetzt kompiliert wird, Alter.
Das halbe Internet wird kompiliert.
Oh, der Encoder kommt aber nicht richtig mit.
Das ganze Fenster pixelt gerade durch das Terminal.
Haben wir es jetzt?
Ja, ich glaube, wir müssten gleich durch sein.
Das finde ich übrigens sehr nice, diese Snapshot-Integration.
Was soll ich noch so wählen?
WL-Clipboard.
Wo ist das?
WL Clipboard
Hier
Ist installiert
Keep Wayland Clipboard even after
Programs close
Alter ich
Ich wills gar nicht wissen
Warum das nicht standardmäßig der Fall ist
Alter
Hör mal bloß auf man
Wie sagt er unter Wayland funktioniert alles nur so zu 80%
So, ähm
Dann wollen wir nochmal gucken
Ne, funktioniert nicht, okay
Dann schauen wir uns mal an, was du hier programmiert hast
Zeig mal her, was haben wir da
Go, du hast ein Go-Programm
Gehackermand
Aha, interesting
Hast du das Vibe coded?
Die Readme sieht so ausführlich aus
Ich hab mal so Readmes
Da denk ich immer direkt gleich AI-Generator.
Okay, was hast du da jetzt
gemacht?
Alter, okay, jetzt wird's kompliziert.
Das check ich jetzt auf die Stelle nicht.
Äh, auf die Schnelle nicht.
Kannst du das in irgendeiner Art und Weise erklären,
was das Problem ist und was du machst?
Aber das ist schon mal cool,
dass du das gefixt hast.
Jetzt ist es natürlich schon ein bisschen bitter, dass man das überhaupt selbst fixen muss, wenn man Wayland verwendet.
Also wäre natürlich nice, wenn das einfach gehen würde, aber es ist halt Wayland.
Da kann man nichts machen.
So, starten wir mal unsere Entwicklungs-VM für den angehenden Rust-Stelz.
Ich bin immer so ein bisschen hin und her gerissen.
Ich muss euch das jetzt mal fragen, wie man das am besten machen.
Wenn ich die Stream-Kategorie, auch bei ganz abgedrehten Themen, so wie heute,
ich meine, 99,999% von Twitch interessieren sich nicht für Rust CLI Tools.
Wenn ich die Kategorie auf Just Chatting stelle,
habe ich das Gefühl, habe ich insgesamt mehr Zuschauer und mehr Interaktion.
Wenn ich es auf Softwareentwicklung stelle, die Kategorie,
dann ist es ein bisschen weniger.
Aber die, die was schreiben, sind
schlauer.
Da habe ich das
Gefühl, da kommen mehr Leute mit Ahnung.
Das ist jetzt natürlich
schwierig. Warum kann es nicht eine
Just Chatting Software
Entwicklung geben?
Dass man alles hat
dazwischen.
Was? Ich habe deine Readme gehatet?
Wirklich? Achso, weil die AI generiert war.
Stimmt.
Hat deine
Programmiersprache jetzt Schleifen?
Ach ja, jetzt hast du
Forlops. Ja, hast du letztens geschrieben.
Massive Forloop.
Richtig high IQ, was wir
hier wieder im Chat, Leute, am Start haben.
Wettebald gibt es eine Vibe-Coding-Kategorie
auf Twitch
Würde mich nicht
wundern
Okay, also wie von Zastool
Forever Tools nutzt ja X11
Da kriegst du mit Xclip den Clipboard-Content
Da wird darauf gepolten
Dann ins Wayland-Clipboard gesetzt
Aha
Könnte man das nicht einfach mit einem Bash-Einzeiler in einer Schleife erledigen?
Theoretisch?
Könnte ich nicht sagen, while true, xclip, pipe nach Wayland Clipboard für den gleichen
Effekt?
Ist natürlich nicht so cool wie irgendwie ein Rust-Programm, das stimmt schon, ja.
Ist das Werbung? Ist das versteckte Werbung hier?
Ganz unauffälliger Username.
ist keine werbung okay na dann die website kenne ich
du musst ja beide states in so ein kalt also im einziger wird das nicht ja aber
das in die andere richtung kopieren hat er bei mir funktioniert vom nie warte
mal was hat bei mir funktioniert ich brauche das umgedrehte nur also
Wayland Clipboard nach X pipen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das bedeuten soll.
Da sind Sources drauf von
Usern, die Comments, alles voll geil.
Was? Moment.
Hä? Das verstehe ich nicht.
Kann man links posten? Besser nicht.
Das klingt nur so
semi-legal, wenn ich da schon irgendwas von Source
und Leaker sehe. Das muss jetzt nicht
unbedingt in Chat.
Bisschen Suske
Acreagle, ja.
Ähm.
Das stimmt.
Aber umgedreht wird es auch funktionieren.
Könnte ich das dann auch benutzen unter KDE?
Dass ich zumindest den Weg
vor M zu Host wieder hinkriege.
Ach so.
Okay.
Das ist ja dann nicht so wild.
Kann man aber doch eigentlich auch auf GitHub gucken.
Aber okay.
Also nichts semi-legales.
Und dann ist ja gut.
So.
Wir switchen jetzt mal rüber.
Set-Servers machen wir zu.
Da machen wir heute nichts.
Oh, der Pepo ist am drücken.
Ja gut, der war gerade Mittagessen.
Da kann es schon mal eilig sein.
So, machen wir nochmal kurz Package-Updates.
Leute, ich würde so gerne genau dieses Setup, was ich jetzt habe, einfach unter Wayland verwenden.
Aber es funktioniert halt nicht.
Das ärgert mich.
Weil die Tage von X, ich sehe es schon einfach kommen, die sind immer weiter gezählt.
Immer mehr Software wird wahrscheinlich in Zukunft gar kein X mehr richtig unterstützen.
Dann werden es Distributionen vernachlässigen.
Dann wird es Probleme geben und irgendwann wird es darüber nach ausgebaut.
Kurz oder lang muss man auf Wayland.
Aber es fronzt halt nicht richtig.
Zumindest in dem Setup, was ich jetzt habe.
Ist es ein Flex?
Moment, was?
Ist es ein Flex in...
Moment, wartet mal kurz.
Kurz hier was aufschreibe.
Ne, kenne ich nicht, aber ich kann ja nachher mal gucken.
Offstream.
Ist es ein Flex, in Bewerbungen zu schreiben, dass man auf Coding-Plattformen wie LeadcodeX Probleme gelöst hat,
oder soll man lieber seine eigenen Sachen aufgeben?
Beides. Ich finde das beides nicht schlecht.
Also, ich bin jetzt natürlich nicht der super Experte, das wisst ihr auch.
Ich habe mich in meinem Leben dreimal oder so beworben und wurde dreimal genommen.
Das hält sich echt sehr in Grenzen
bei der Erfahrung, was Bewerbung angeht.
Aber
ich kann dir nur sagen, bei meiner letzten Bewerbung
da habe ich
mein GitHub mit gepostet
und das nicht als Entwickler.
Ich arbeite ja nicht als Entwickler.
Das als
Linux-Engineer habe ich mich beworben.
und
das ist jetzt auch da, wo ich arbeite
letztendlich und
da habe ich mein GitHub-Profil mitgeschickt
da gab es unter anderem den Fiat Champ
da haben wir uns in einem Vorstellungsgespräch
auch drüber unterhalten, also dass ich mein GitHub
Profil mitgeschickt habe
auch als Nicht-Entwickler kam sehr gut an
und wenn das was ist, wo es
hier um
um Softwareentwicklung geht, finde ich das gar nicht
verkehrt
muss man halt gucken, wie man das
wie man das verpackt.
Ich habe 50 Leadcode-Probleme gelöst.
Ist vielleicht nicht so spannend.
Aber wenn du irgendwie
sagst, dass du dich auch gerne
mit Leadcode-Plattformen
aktiv bist, weil du
bla bla bla, irgendwas schönes ausdenken musst,
kann man das, denke ich, schon reinschreiben.
Du hast den Wubblers GitHub verlinkt.
Was meinst du?
in der, in meiner Bewerbung.
Stimmt, du hast recht, es war viermal.
Warum weiß der, warum weiß
der Chat besser als ich, wie oft ich mich
beworben hab?
Der Chat ist einfach
zu high IQ, zu viele Leute subscribed.
Ja, aber ich hab den Wobblos GitHub verlinkt in der Bewerbung
So sieht's aus
Hab ich gemacht
So, nochmal hier updaten
Oh ne, shit Leute, wir haben ein Problem
Die Jetbrains-Session ist abgelaufen.
Da muss ich mich jetzt einloggen.
Ich hoffe, die IDEs, die funzen noch,
ohne dass ich jetzt eingeloggt bin.
Lass mal kurz gucken.
Wir machen nur Drust.
Gucken wir mal, ob Drust-Stells startet.
Prage.
Okay, es scheint noch zu gehen.
Es scheint noch zu gehen.
Ich habe nicht vor, was zu leaken.
Da muss ich euch dann kurz ausmachen.
Aber jetzt erstmal Reboot.
PotatoBob, guckst du bei Gitterprojekten auch,
ob die offene issues haben und ob wieder auf reagiert wird
weil weil
was ist wenn du eine software hast auf github die 50 offene issues hat aber
alles sind Userfehler und der Programmierer
kann da gar nichts dafür.
Ich spreche aus Erfahrung.
Alles Anwenderfehler.
Okay.
Da hätte ich
Probleme bei dir.
Ja, das Problem ist, ich kann beispielsweise nicht jede Software starten.
Hast du doch gerade gesehen in der VM.
Ich kann beispielsweise Kitty und Westterm nicht starten.
Unter Sway in der VM.
Aber ich kann es starten unter KD.
Okay, gut, gut.
Immerhin, immerhin.
Wenigstens siehst du das auch so.
Da kann man ja nichts dafür als Entwickler, wenn die Leute alle zu blöd sind, das zu verwenden.
Ja, geil. Und das nächste Software, die nicht startet, auch nicht benutzen.
So, VM ist neu gestartet.
Start X. Die Tage sind gezählt, Leute.
Wo Start X angesagt war.
Ups.
bald ist es was ist eigentlich das gegenstück bei wayland gar nichts direkt direkt die desktop
starten weil er ist ja kein server in dem sinn so zack also firefox aufmachen ja hallo firefox
please nicht abkacken sagt terminal aufmachen so was ich gefunden habe was ich heute mal ausprobieren
Wurdest du bei der Bewerbung nicht gefragt, was das ist?
Das Bild, Alter.
Das ist viel schlecht, Mann.
Was ein dummes Projektfilm, Alter.
Ich glaube das hat sogar damals jemand im Chat gebaut.
Six years ago.
Wie hättest du das erklärt? So ich hätte gesagt das ist ein Emote und die Software die hat Kameras,
Kamerastreams verarbeitet, deswegen ist es ein Emote mit Kameras auf den Augen.
Also, so, jetzt mal.
KDE wird auch noch Wayland-only sein.
Ja, ja, ich weiß, ich weiß, es wird immer mehr, immer mehr in der Richtung.
Was ich gefunden habe für Rust, weil ich mir gedacht habe, das muss ich mal angucken.
Das da habe ich gefunden, damit kann man Rust Terminal-Programme erstellen, die cool aussehen.
Also, ich muss euch mal sagen, wie ich drauf gekommen bin.
ich habe mir heute morgen gedacht ich würde gerne und da muss ich jetzt ein
bisschen ausholen wisst ihr was er da bist nicht eltern erdab sagt jemand was
was das ist er da ich kannte das bis vor kurzem gar nicht
wo es kennt ihr oder wo ist die abfrage google.com so dass das das habt ihr
wahrscheinlich schon gesehen wo man Whois-Abfragen machen kann.
Rdub ist das neue Whois.
Guck, kann man zum Beispiel sagen hier client domain woblos.tv und dann
sieht man hier die ganzen Infos dazu zu woblos.tv und man sieht unter anderem
auch und das ist mega nice
Expire
Date. Das heißt,
man könnte ein Monitoring
Tool programmieren, dass
das Expire Date checkt von
Domains. Das ist gegenüber Whois
auch schon, aber Whois war sehr
lückenbehaftet,
was das angeht.
Und du kannst Domains snipen. Genau.
So, und hier siehst du bla bla bla
bla bla bla bla bla.
Aber das ist mega nice und ich wollte mir dafür ein Tool bauen, wo ich einfach checken kann, ob meine Domains abgelaufen sind.
Ach ja, übrigens, by the way, Deutschland funzt nicht.
Es gibt vom DENIC, vom DENIC gibt es auch sowas, aber da stehen leider Expiration Dates nicht drin.
Ich habe aber die Hoffnung, sollte eine Domain nah am Expiren sein, dann steht es da drin.
hoffe ich mal müssen wir mal gucken die nächste de domain ich habe expert glaube ich am ersten
april 2026 also in drei monaten da werde ich mal gucken ob da was drin steht so und da habe ich
mir gedacht da wäre doch ein cool wäre es doch cool wenn es ein komando zeilen tool gibt was
diese infos schön anzeigt so deine domain läuft da unter ab und am besten aber das machen wir jetzt
nicht mehr geht es wirklich nur um die kommandozeilen geschichte heute eigentlich will
ich daraus ein monitoring tool bauen also irgendwas wo du es kreppen kannst so metrik
mäßig skript kannst und dann ein monitoring tool einbauen das war ja überhaupt nicht und
bei der gelegenheit bin ich halt drauf kommen wie macht man eigentlich in rust schöne komandozeilen
programme sondern was ich dann gemacht habe ist ich bin tatsächlich hier gut hier nicht aber
machen wir es mal machen was doch mal in der google einmal gucken was da rauskommt ich brauche
eine Alternative zu
Spectre Console. Das ist ein
.NET Programm. Hier, warte mal.
.NET Library,
wo man solche schönen Sachen
beispielsweise mitmachen kann.
So,
Command Line.
Hübsch.
Guck,
sowas kann man damit basteln.
Tabellen und Progress Bars
und solche Geschichten.
Das ist Spectre Console.
Meinst du mit Kommandozeilenprogramm sowas wie
Tui? Nicht richtig
Tui ist ja für mich quasi so eine eigene
Anwendung im Fullscreen im jeweiligen Terminal
Tab
Das will ich nicht, ich will eher so
einen
ein bisschen hübschere Kommandozeilenausgabe
haben, dass das Ding auch mal
eine Tabelle rendern kann und sowas, ich will kein
Fullscreen
Sowas wie Rich, genau
Genau, Spectre Console ist quasi
Rich in
in .NET.
Ja.
Genau, sowas will ich.
Ja, man.
Da können wir nochmal die AI fragen.
Ich brauche jetzt Respekt der Console oder Ridge
nur für Rust.
Was gibt's da?
Machen wir mal hier
den Vergleich.
Mal gucken, welche AI
die besseren Ergebnisse liefert.
Wurde geupdatet.
Was?
Webfetch. DuckDuckGo.
Ist okay. Darfst du.
Ach, Rich gibt es.
Es gibt Rich-AS.
Interessant.
Guck mal hier. Rich-AS habe ich schon gesehen.
Okay, lassen wir die AI
hier mal rödeln im Hintergrund. Wobei, ich warte mal,
bis die fertig ist, weil die muss ja noch Webfetchen und alles.
Eieiei, die hört ja gar nicht mehr auf
zu Webfetchen.
Ich habe es halt so eingestellt, dass der
Webfetch immer bestätigen muss.
Ich werde jetzt einfach mal sagen,
webfetch ist erlaubt komplett ok except always dem github rich es gibt es
rich python library in das ist nice
jetzt drum
gab es hier nicht immer eine verlinkung oben auf ach so das ist bei crates das ist ja docs
crates 25 tage okay vielleicht ist das die die library schlechthin ich bin einer der ersten
der sie gefunden hat last week dass das sieht auf jeden fall schon mal so aus wie was was ich
haben will.
Max, geht's nur mir so oder
werden Websites immer langsamer? Ich warte mal.
Das ist so. Das ist so.
Und es ist immer mehr Bullshit.
Es ist immer mehr
Bullshit auf der, ähm,
auf den Webseiten. Mittlerweile,
wenn du eine Webseite aufmachst, hast du ja drei Pop-Ups
plus, also so,
Cookie-Gedöns, Datenschutz-Gedöns, Achtung,
hier und da musst du erstmal drei Sachen wegklicken.
Und dann hast du noch so eklige Features wie Endless Call zum Beispiel.
Dann musst du noch ein Captcha beantworten, ja.
Ja, ich finde Rust ganz nice bis jetzt.
Ja.
meint ihr, meint ihr, dass es wirklich
ähm
wie soll ich sagen
gut, gute
Handarbeit, dieses Projekt, oder meint
ihr, dass es AI-Slob, der hat einfach gesagt
bei irgendeinem, bei irgendeinem KI-Model
nehm Python Rich und
bastel mir das
nach Rust um
Wobei ich sagen muss, die Readme sieht nicht so sehr nach AI-Slop aus.
Naja.
Nee, eigentlich sieht die Readme nicht so schlimm nach AI-Slop aus.
Also, tja.
Gehen wir mal von aus, das ist legit.
Okay, gucken wir mal weiter.
Aber eigentlich wollte ich mir das hier angucken.
Weil das eine ziemlich weit verbreitete Library ist, so wie es aussieht.
Was geht? Rust-Stells geht.
Dass das eine ziemlich weit verbreitete Library sein muss.
Guck mal, 17.000 Sterne.
Und damit kann man Kommandozeilen-Anwendungen basteln, die hübsch aussehen.
Und das müssen wir mal ausprobieren, wie das tut.
Also was ich will, ist...
Ich habe mir vorhin die Hilfeseite schon mal ein bisschen angeguckt.
Was ich will, ist...
Hm, wo ist es denn?
Ich habe doch vorhin schon was...
irgendwas mit inline inline viewport genau so was will ich im endeffekt haben also sprich
das ist einfach nur den output hübsch macht aber nicht die komplette konsole übernimmt so was hier
inline viewport und da gehen wir jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen ein bisschen bei example text
aus und gucken wie das funzt bei der gelegenheit können wir jetzt gleich noch was neues checken
nämlich ach so was hat hier meine ausgespuckt was wir vernehmen soll was wir nehmen sollte
die besten was alle dem suspekt der konvention und rich für thermal funktionalität vt direkt
der rich port github ollie reis rich rs ist das was wir gerade schon offen hatten ja mit
7 Stars. Deswegen ist es wichtig, dass die KI Zugriff aufs Internet hat, dass man sowas
nachgucken kann, weil ansonsten zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo die trainiert wurde, gab es das Projekt dann
wahrscheinlich noch gar nicht. Kann das auch LVVM? Ich brauche unbedingt View Models im CLI.
Das ist so offensichtlicher Cheatbait.
okay das wird auch vorgeschlagen oder konsole plus dialoge
modern terminal gucken wir mal da rein
russ library for rich top vor fünf jahren okay das fällt schon mal raus term painter
der farben brauchen wir nicht ich will schon so was wie eine tabelle und so malen können
oder beizutragen war das ernst gemeint ich habe keine ahnung ich habe nichts gefunden
bei mir was sind also zumindest mit weich mit nichts zufrieden was in 24 gig grafikspeicher passt
ich war im code mix
rich ross okay da gibt es jetzt guck mal da gibt es noch mehrere mehrere ports anscheinend fast
rich das sieht nach ei aus leute
das ist doch alles die haben doch alle hier einstellt gemacht oder die haben
gesagt hier neben dem rich von python rich und da eine rastversion draus not
Etablierte Rust-Alternativen.
Rust-Native-Alternativen.
Der aktuelle Standard für...
Comfytable.
Kann Tabellen im Terminal malen.
Aha, Comfytable.
Termimat.
Der Markdown direkt im...
Ich würde sagen, wir probieren es tatsächlich mal mit dem da aus und schauen uns das mal
an, wie das funzt.
Bei der Gelegenheit können wir jetzt gleich mal meine Projekt-Templating-Geschichte testen.
Ich muss mal kurz pullen.
Hier, pull.
Ja, ist schon aktuell.
Okay, dann machen wir mal.
Cookie Cutter, Templates, Rust.
Das Ding heißt Domain Rust, Domain Champ.
und schon haben wir ein fertiges wenn ich das jetzt noch richtig schreibe
von aber ein fertiges projekt ist gefordert
verbinden in den container mit rober
gespannt wie ratatouille funktioniert ob das taugt
weil ich bin ein fan von schönen terminal applications
und wir uns einmal neu connecten dass ich meine idee eröffnen kann geht noch von
jetzt macht nichts das nicht schlimm wenn geht noch frauen ist brauche ich in dem container
hier auch nicht unbedingt. Hier mal kurz auf dem dritten Desktop, dass die IDE im richtigen Fenster aufgeht.
Da sind wir.
Readme. Ja gut, die Readme ist ziemlich minimalistisch gerade. Aber immerhin habe ich schon mal eine
Readme. Open. Workspaces. App. Gut. Können wir loslegen.
cargo kann weg dann aber das mal zu dass wir in der ssh verbindung drauf bekommen da sind wir
erstmal das beispiel ding kompilieren da habe ich aber noch viel zu viele packages drin
da habe ich auch viel zu viele packages trainer kommt hier was da alles drin habe
in meiner cargo tommel web server es sind clap brauchen war tokio also axum brauchen
wir waschen wobei wer weiß nicht vielleicht kriegt es auch ein web von der denkwad lassen
wir einfach mal die standard dinger trainer juckt ja nicht großartig ok also dann wollen
mal gucke wie man beispielsweise eine schöne tabelle macht inline view wir
bekommen uns erst mal dieses exemplar würde ich sagen also was passiert hier
Alter, what the fuck, Alter, das ist ja ein huge Example.
Oh, arme Katz.
F-Pro-Commer schreibt, er musste am Samstag mit seiner Katze zum Notdienst, weil die drei Tage nichts wirklich was gegessen hat.
Die hatte Schiss vor den Böllern, ja.
Arzt meint zum Glück nur, es war
der Silvesterstress, aber ein Ultraschall
war teuer. Ich weiß gar nicht
mehr, was es bei Chico gekostet hat.
Ich war ja sogar
mit Chico mal beim Augenarzt. Es gibt
wirklich Augenärzte für Katzen mittlerweile.
Das war alles auch nicht billig.
Aber man macht es ja gerne für
seine Katz.
Okay, Leute.
das sieht ja schon mal richtig advanced aus hier dann führen wir das doch mal in
meine cargo tommel hinzu
das haben wir denn hier zur auswahl die idee ist einfach bock kann man nicht
sagen einfach wie das alles auto completed und so echt nice guck mal kurz auf github ob das passt
hier mit den tags ob man die richtige version haben ja auch 30 wurde released widgets noch
V30 wurde released.
Okay, dann müssen wir hier auch gleich
30 nehmen.
Warum gibt es hier nur 30 Alpha und nicht
30? Was ist da los, Leute?
Warum gibt es die...
Warum...
Eigentlich sollte es da 30 geben.
Guck mal mal.
Jetzt hat es es gecheckt.
Aber der checkt immer noch nicht, dass es 30 gibt.
Komisch.
Ja, ja, das ist gefühlt alles 0 Punkt irgendwas immer.
Da machen wir jetzt einfach mal hier so.
So.
Letzte, die letzte 30er Version.
Okay, also auf geht's.
Wir gucken uns mal dieses Beispiel hier an.
Gibt's, warte mal, minimal Hello World.
Das machen wir mal.
Das ist auch wirklich minimal.
Ja, man muss ja erstmal verstehen, was da eigentlich passiert.
Also, was haben wir hier?
Wir haben eine Main-Funktion, Terminal.
Okay, verstehe, verstehe.
Dann Loop Draw, Fail to Draw Frame.
Achso, und hier crasht es dann.
Okay, alles klar.
If Matches.
Warum braucht man dafür Makros?
Was macht denn das Matches-Makro?
Matches?
Returns?
Ob eine Expression
das Provided Pattern matcht.
Warum brauche ich ein Matches-Makro,
wenn ich einfach
Pattern-Matching machen kann?
Das verstehe ich nicht so genau.
Das ist doch dann eigentlich viel lesbarer.
Das habe ich noch nicht so genau gecheckt.
Also was machen die hier?
Terminal Draw.
If Matches.
Das hier ist doch eigentlich nur, wenn eine Taste gedrückt wird, riecht er ab, oder?
restore ist wahrscheinlich dass das wieder restored wie es ursprünglich war
aber ich will minimal viewport haben dass das inline ist
also schauen wir doch mal machen wir doch mal das hier
Weiß nicht, ob ich das hier
Essung machen soll.
Terminal.
Ratatouille in den Loop.
Brauch man nicht.
Keine Loop. Wir machen einfach
ein Sleep rein.
Wir machen einfach
Tokio, Time,
Sleep, 5 Sekunden.
Bam.
So, und jetzt
muss das Ding noch...
getrout werden aha frame import text import
ich sag keine ahnung was import from text ok so und jetzt sollte der hello world rendern richtig
Vielleicht soll ich es mal von Hand runnen.
Cargo run.
Ah, das funzt nicht.
Ich bin ja auch dumm.
Ich rufe ja das Draw nirgendwo auf.
Hier.
Terminal Draw.
Das muss ich natürlich noch machen.
Und der Break.
Mal gucken, ob das mit Ctrl-C auch funzt.
Ohne was.
Hello World, okay.
Nice.
Der frisst komplett Steuerung C.
Also schon mal keine allzu gute Idee.
Dann muss man die App, muss man wirklich killen, dass das funktioniert hat.
Na gut, dann müssen wir doch diese, diese Geschichte hier machen.
Aber ich will das ja eigentlich gar nicht.
Ich will das ja, ich will das ja inline malen, so wie hier.
Also ich will ja gar nicht, dass das komplett Fullscreen das Ding in Beschlag nimmt.
Das will ich ja gar nicht.
Ich will, dass das hier so bleibt.
Also dass es einfach nur so unterm, unterm Command kommt.
wenn das Command fertig ist, wieder
zurück in die Shell geht.
So, jetzt mal gucken, wie das... Ah, hier.
Terminal? Was ist
Color...
Irie?
Was ist
Color Irie?
Hab ich gar nicht.
GitHub. Was will ich da
sehen?
Custom? Nice.
Archived.
custom books for colorful human oriented error reports via panics
also schönere fehler das braucht man nicht
ist denn das trade objekt based error handling type for easy and dramatic rust reporting was
nicht sicher wozu ich das brauche aber das werden wir uns jetzt nicht weiter
mit beschäftigen sondern damit also import das wollen wir haben hier
terminal options inline so dass tracing mama raus hier
stimmt wir haben keine eros geht ja immer alles first try bei uns ja sorry habe ich
vergessen.
So, und jetzt
bin ich echt ein bisschen...
Machen wir jetzt einfach mal hier.
Ich muss das
Input Handling
Input Handling, wo kommt das her?
Input Handling?
Das ist eine Funktion, die ist irgendwo unten drunter definiert
Okay
Downloads?
Da fände ich ein minimales Beispiel irgendwie ganz praktisch
Input Handling
Tickrate
Boah, jetzt wird...
Event Match Key
Ich will doch gar kein Input handeln
Wir machen das einfach so
Wir machen jetzt einen Loop
Und malen einfach
Fünfmal den Frame
Und
Mit einem Sleep dazwischen
Äh
Vor
4 E-In
oder keine Ahnung, 10 oder 5
5 Mal malen wir das jetzt hier.
Tokio
Time Sleep, eine Sekunde dazwischen
warten
und zack, das für, zum
Testen reicht das ja voll und ganz. Okay,
zack, Cargo Run.
Okay, jetzt ist es Inline.
Das ist schon mal gut. Das ist sehr gut.
Äh.
Oder auch nicht.
Doch, genau.
Jetzt ist es gut.
Dass man nicht abbrechen kann, ist auch
schon ziemlich pepega, dass man da irgendwie
eigenes Input Handling machen muss.
Das ist nicht Ctrl-C
direkt.
Checkt. Komisch.
Ja, aber jetzt haben wir was.
So, okay. Jetzt wissen wir,
wie man Hello World ausgibt. Den Rest können wir uns
erstmal sparen hier.
Wir können doch mal kurz überfliegen, was die sonst noch so machen.
gut downloads ist für uns vollkommen irrelevant progress worker input handling
preventive ich habe noch nichts gesehen also was macht er hier loop for tick rate
duration if no events send tick event alle 200 millisekunden tickt er und dann
dann readet er quasi den Input. Gut, das kann ich mir mal bei Gelegenheit
angucken dann. Workas ist für uns jetzt auch irrelevant, hier kann man Progress Bars malen,
wie es aussieht downloads ran ok das ist richard schulter mann und frau fremd das
ist aber schon wieder echt das teilweise schon wieder richtig eklige eklige
syntax hier also richtig richtig griffig ist das nicht so wirklich okay das hier
sind die input events wenn quit dann break ok da ist tick
als interessiert mich jetzt alles nicht hier das ist das interessante blog
progress
Die ist schon ein bisschen pepega teilweise so ein Tags.
Draw Frame, Draw Frame.
Wir gucken jetzt mal, wie man Tabellen malt.
Table.
Wir machen mal eine Tabelle.
Widgets.
Table.
widgets table so will ich aber nicht dass meine table aussieht
minimalistische beispiele würde ihn gut tun ich will einfach nur was ausgeben ich will
kein input handling oder sonst was machen also c++ hat std mono state habe
ich letztens gelernt was ganz super geil benannt ist table color terminal
App new.
Nee, kann ich nicht einfach eine Tabelle malen?
Okay, Table. Wo wird hier eine Table gemalt?
Table.
Table State, Table Color.
Ich will einfach nur eine Tabelle malen.
Ich will da nicht drin rumscrollen oder so.
Lass es mal nicht so kompliziert machen.
Next Row. Ja, das ist mit Input Handling.
Ich will einfach nur eine Tabelle malen.
Sonst nix.
Da müssen wir doch in Draw gucken letztendlich.
Hier, Terminal, Draw, Frame, Self.
Ja, das ist doch schon echt wieder...
Die Syntaxe ist wirklich pepega.
Terminal, Draw, Frame, Self, Draw, Frame.
Was?
Da checke ich nicht mal, was das macht.
Also, anonyme Funktion,
um dann eine interne Funktion aufzurufen.
Und das Ergebnis
dann zurückzugeben an
Terminal Draw.
Okay.
Na gut.
Draw. Render Table.
Okay, hier ist das interessante,
was mich interessiert. Render Table.
header style, row style
header
row
ne, wo malt er denn jetzt die
wo wird dann eigentlich die Tabelle jetzt gemalt
rows, hier, hä
ne, hier, table
new
das ist die Tabelle
hier wird die Tabelle gemalt
render
stateful widget
area
ok
und muss selbst etwas okay das das muss ich mir mal kurz gibt es denn auch
wo sind wir hier gibt es denn auch ein nicht stateful widget denn der widget
okay das gibt es auch da kann man sich mit state schon mal sparen so was ist area
area rekt
woher direkt get rekt
hier frame area wo wir haben okay hier oben hat er das ja schon ja ja so war das haben
ok frame text können wir uns sparen aber nicht und jetzt und jetzt rennen wir eine
tabelle new table das ist aber auch in diesen dingen hier erstens das mal copy
pasten table also was bin ich hier sehend
Länge?
Das ist...
Hä?
Kann man das auch weglassen?
Gucken wir mal gleich.
Also, Rose.
Was nimmt denn das Ding hier überhaupt für Argumente?
Ja, geil, geil.
Das ist jetzt halt wieder Rust,
wo man erstmal checken muss, was es eigentlich macht.
Into Iterator,
Item into Row.
OnKS, Alter.
Header.
Row Highlight Style.
Cell Highlight Style.
Das wollen wir eigentlich alles nicht.
Highlight Symbol. Was macht das? Set the symbol to be displayed in front of the selected row.
Da brauchen wir nix. Background brauchen wir auch nicht. Highlight Spacing. Highlight Spacing is
the space allocated for the selected row. Was? Keine Ahnung, wir wollen auch Spacing nicht
Ich will es so minimalistisch wie möglich haben.
Ein Header wäre auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt.
So, Rows.
Was ist Rows?
Rows.
Self-Items.
Äh, was?
Ja, ich brauche eine Tabelle, weil ich eine Tabelle malen will.
Rows.
Moment.
Ah ja, das ist jetzt die Farbe.
Item.
Item into was?
Row. Aha.
Wir brauchen irgendwas, was letztendlich ein
Row-Vektor ist, sozusagen.
Boah, das ist...
Also die Syntax ist krass kompliziert wieder.
Die Syntax ist wirklich heftig, ja.
Muss es unbedingt das sein?
Nö, nicht unbedingt, aber das ist wohl mit Abstand die verbreitetste Library für Konsolen-UIs in Rust.
Wir machen mal kurz den Header.
Der ist ja noch relativ easy zu verstehen.
Header.
Sell from.
Das da?
Hoffentlich habe ich das Richtige genommen.
Row import.
Header style.
Brauche keinen Header-Style.
Header-Style gibt es nicht.
Header.
Kann ich das jetzt einfach löschen und es geht trotzdem einfach dann so?
Äh, by the way.
Warum geht eigentlich das Auto formatieren nicht?
Warum geht mein Formatieren nicht?
Format.
File.
reformat fall doch safe format actions on safe format code dass er ja okay
Rose
Vielleicht ist die Lip zu viel
Ah
Es ist mit Abstand die weit verbreitste Lip
Für Terminal Interfaces
Also Spectre Console trifft bei mir
In .NET wirklich so genau das Zwischending
Zwischen, es kann genug
Alles, was man braucht, oder fast alles, was man braucht, ist relativ easy zu benutzen.
Okay, Rose.
Schauen wir uns das mal kurz an.
Verbreitet und gleich gut.
Na, jetzt muss sie ja erst mal was 17.000 Sterne kriegen.
Ja, und wenn das totaler Schrott ist, wird sie das wahrscheinlich nicht bekommen.
Ich lass mal diese ganzen Konstru...
Strains weg.
Also was macht er denn hier?
Also wir machen jetzt einfach mal
hier einen Vektor.
Let blub.
Oder Items. Nennen wir es Items.
Gleich Vektor
mit 1
oder keine Ahnung. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
So.
Weiß nicht genau, was wir eigentlich machen wollen.
Items.
Ina Maraid. Map.
Ich bin hardcore verwirrt, warum es da zwei Sachen überhaupt gibt.
Bei einem Vector aus Int.
Warum gibt es da zwei Sachen?
Warum gibt es da nicht nur I?
Warum? Hä? MonkaS?
Warum gibt es da zwei Sachen, wenn ich nen...
einen Vektor mit
Ins Iterator. Es gibt
Use Size.
Oder, ach,
das ist der Index, jetzt verstehe ich es.
Das ist der Index und das ist das
eigentlich, das ist die eigentliche Zahl.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Ja, aber der Index und der Zahl,
naja gut, Index fängt bei 0 an.
Also,
Also Item, Data.
So, das ist halt eine Zahl.
MapCon, was passiert hier jetzt?
Also, der legt eine Row.
Okay, im Prinzip legt er eine Row an.
Let Row gleich Row.
default?
Kann man das so machen?
Okay.
Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Das ist jetzt zwar eine leere Tabelle,
aber es sollte zumindest mal
kompilieren und laufen, hä?
Hä?
Ah ja gut,
wahrscheinlich, weil das hier leer ist.
Wahrscheinlich, weil das hier leer ist.
Eins.
Zwei.
Drei.
Okay, das ist Fuss.
So, mal gucken, was passiert, wenn ich das jetzt laufen lasse.
Okay, wir haben sowas wie einen Header hier, ja?
Das ist sowas wie ein Header.
Moment, durfte ich Ctrl-C drücken?
Hat es das gecheckt?
Nee, nicht wirklich.
Na immerhin
Immerhin malt es
Eine Tabelle
Sieht zwar noch nicht schön aus
Aber okay
So
Jetzt will ich natürlich
Dass es eine ordentliche Tabelle ist
Die er hier malt
Was gibt es da jetzt alles für Dinger
Style
gibt es? Okay, Style.
Map, Content.
Content?
Wie kriege ich da den...
Wie kann ich jetzt setzen, was
da in der Row angezeigt wird?
Sell from? Text from?
Ah, eine Row
besteht aus mehreren Cells, oder wie?
nur da ich das checke
also brauche ich da jetzt quasi noch nen
ne ne nicht default
ok da braucht man jetzt hier nen
cell iterator also sprich
z cells gleich
vector
content keck weh so machen wir mal jedes new line zeug weg so und jetzt hier selbst okay
nice. Jetzt haben wir hier die Row
mit den Cells drinnen.
Und jetzt sollte der ja von der
Idee her
zumindest ein bisschen was malen noch.
Hast du eigentlich Battlefield 6 gespielt?
Wenn ja, war es 6? Nicht?
Ich habe mein Rechner neu installiert für Battlefield 6
und habe es dann nie gespielt. Oho, guck mal.
Achso, ah, weil das nur Länge 1 ist.
Jetzt verstehe ich das.
Darf man das weglassen?
Ne.
Jetzt check ich das.
Das ist die Breite
Die Breite pro
Spalte.
Ja.
Du brauchst ein Video mit dem Kabum und dem Friseur
Ey, da hätte ich halt richtig Bock drauf
Aber so ein Oldschool Video aufzunehmen
Also so ganz
So ganz habe ich so nicht gecheckt
Aber zumindest wissen wir jetzt, wie wir da einen Inhalt reinbekommen.
Und wenn ich jetzt...
Okay, machen wir das mal anders.
Header.
Machen wir mal hier.
Chat.
Chatter.
Emote.
Keine Ahnung.
Text.
So, irgendwie sowas.
Gleich mal den Emoji-Support testen, ob das ordentlich funktioniert.
So, und jetzt brauchen wir quasi Pro...
Das mit dem Format können wir uns ja eigentlich auch schenken.
Jetzt brauchen wir pro Spalte, brauchen wir sowas hier.
Also das erste hier ist der Name.
Wen haben wir da hier?
TommyK9991 zum Beispiel.
Dann haben wir noch den RF Programmer und XSGT Silver X oder irgendwie so.
Ach ne.
Silver und dann das I kleiner.
Ihr macht es doch immer kompliziert.
So, das sind die Chatters.
Dann
Ach ne, ha, das stimmt ja schon mal gar nicht
Das ist ja schon mal Blödsinn
Das ist jetzt ja quasi die
Komplette Zeile
Die man da eintragen muss
Das bringt es jetzt, jetzt wird ja
Guck mal, jetzt schreibt er nämlich einfach die Namen hier untereinander
So, zack, äh, ne
Immer wieder das gleiche
Genau, so rum
Weil, ähm
5 5 mal ja das natürlich blut sind
Aber immerhin so und wie das heißt hier brauche ich jetzt so was wie text
w
Genau das habt ihr geschrieben keck weg größer 0 w und jetzt gibt es hier in den emote
Ich meine, ich habe doch meinen Emoji Picker.
Emoji Picker.
Äh, Dissorted Face.
Genau, das da.
Das, genau das habt ihr gepostet.
Okay, das funzt schon mal.
Jetzt ist nur noch die Frage, wie wir eine ordentliche Tabelle malen.
Ja, also sowas mit, mit Zeilen und, also so, so, so, so, so.
Spalten und so, dass man das, dass man das sieht.
dass es ungefähr ein bisschen so aussieht wie spektre console table oder rich table python
tables spektre console table ja dass das dass das irgendwie so in der richtung aussieht
Und so was trinken.
Ja, so was hier in der Richtung will ich haben.
So was da.
Genau, oder so was hier.
Das ist in dem Exempel drin,
den musst du nur finden.
So.
Roll.
Highlight Style. Column
Highlight Style. Cell Highlight
Style.
Highlight Symbol.
Also was
Highlight Symbol sein soll, habe ich immer noch nicht gecheckt.
Mal das Beispiel angucken.
Ah, hier vorne ist das Symbol,
oder? Das da.
Ne, das brauchen wir nicht.
Ich will ja gar keine Tabelle,
wo man was auswählen kann und so.
Gedulds da.
Overrated, outdated, she baited.
Das brauchen wir nicht.
Also, wie
funzt das jetzt?
Selected
Row Style.
Header Style.
Ich will sowas wie einen Border Style
eigentlich haben.
gibt so was wie
Border?
Ne
Bold
Style
Flex
Was?
That's how extra space is distributed among Calvuses.
Flex.
Okay, wie man das formatiert, gucken wir uns danach an.
Highlight Spacing.
Was?
Highlight Spacing ist das Spacing, das
allocated for the Selection Symbol.
Ne, das wollen wir nicht.
Highlight Symbol. Ne.
Row Highlight Style.
Ich würde sagen, das wollen wir haben, oder?
Hier.
Style New.
BG.
Wir wollen ja eigentlich nur...
Wir wollen nicht den... Nein, das wollen wir nicht.
Wir wollen
den Rahmen...
Den Rahmen...
...wollen wir haben.
Wie könnte man das...
Wie könnte man den Rahmen...
Das Ding hat ja offensichtlich auch einen...
Hat das einen Rahmen?
Das hat nicht wirklich einen Rahmen, oder?
Aber der Futter hat einen Rahmen.
Guckt mal.
So will ich das haben im Endeffekt.
Okay.
Block.
Bordert.
Ah.
Okay.
Lock und dann
Lock, Bordered
border type double style
fg
border style fg colors in welcher form
Ach so macht man das, okay.
Color.
Ne, gibt's nicht.
Wo kommt das her mit Color?
Color?
Tailwind?
Was?
Ich bin verwirrt.
Wir sind in einem Rust CLI Tool, was hat das mit Tailwind zu tun?
das finde ich jetzt äußerst verwirrend
wo kommt das hierher dieses color
Style.
Kommt das hierher?
Style?
Light Magenta.
Okay, ich bin voll...
Ich bin extrem verwirrt.
Wo kommt...
Wo kommt da dieses...
Wo kommt da dieses Color her an der Stelle?
Und wo kommt Tailwind her?
Das verwirrt mich gerade total.
Palette.
Geht nicht einfach.
Wollen wir mal gucken?
Moment, Color.
Muss das groß schreiben.
So geht das.
Color Cray.
Okay.
Bisschen weird.
Ah, guck mal da.
Wir haben...
Also richtig gut...
hat er das jetzt nicht gemalt?
Der muss am Ende noch
einen New Line printen.
Das kriegen wir auch noch gefixt.
Okay, jetzt haben wir zumindest schon mal
einen Rahmen drum.
Wobei ich ja ehrlich gesagt gar kein...
Ich will ja hier dazwischen...
Ich will es ja...
Ich will es im Endeffekt haben
wie das hier.
So.
Also um das hinzukriegen, brauchen wir wahrscheinlich...
Okay, gucken wir mal. Wir fragen mal hier AI-Stells.
Using I want table as borders.
So, schauen wir einfach mal gucken.
Show me code example.
Alter!
Okay, das ist dumm.
Table border.
Make table support.
Collapse borders in the layout.
Ja genau, das hätte ich gerne.
Sag bloß, das geht nicht.
Das Ding kann gefühlt
alles, aber keine
Tabellen malen, oder was?
Das glaube ich nicht.
Ja genau,
So was will ich haben im Endeffekt.
Was ist das?
Tablet?
Das ist eine Rust.
Es gibt hier extra Rust-Dings, um Tabellen zu malen.
MonkaS, Alter.
die reden da jetzt irgendwie seit 32 monka ist was
das geht nicht das glaube ich nicht das glaube ich nicht ich glaube nicht dass
es kann doch nicht sein die unterstützen gott um die welt für terminal sachen aber
eine Tabelle ordentlich malen. Geht nicht.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Das probieren wir jetzt nochmal aus.
Das ist ja schon mal nicht verkehrt.
So, hier Block.
Block Type. Was haben wir da sonst noch?
Double, Heavy, Double.
Light, Double, Triple.
Quad, Triple.
plane.
Guck mal, die haben sogar Beispiele hier.
Das finde ich cool. Plane, plane.
Ja, das sieht doch
prinzipiell schon mal nicht schlecht aus.
Und jetzt brauchen wir eigentlich nur noch
Striche pro.
Oh, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Nicht Striche pro.
Wir brauchen...
Ey, wir brauchen eigentlich
nur eine Separation von
Header
zu...
Ne, so will ich das gar nicht. Ich will das im Prinzip
so haben. Zwischen Header und Rest.
Das wird doch schon komplett reichen.
Also eigentlich brauche ich nur hier
einen Strich drunter, sonst nix.
Wo hab ich denn hier? Da.
Linux ist super. Das ist doch genau das, was ich schon aufhab.
Oder?
Das ist was anderes. Ne, das ist genau das.
So, Header.
Kann man jetzt nicht sagen,
den Header? Wo haben wir hier den?
Ich geb dir Header, Alter.
Alter.
Das haben die Halo-Kinders früher
immer gesagt. Header, Alter.
Ich drück dem ein Header.
Zu Zeiten, als Halo-Spiel noch
cool war.
Was passiert eigentlich, wenn ich sage
32, äh 23.
Und jetzt ist es super fett.
Kann man jetzt hier sagen, Border?
Moment, Hedda kann keinen Border haben?
Moment, Moment, ich bin jetzt verwirrt.
Wie, wie, wie, wie?
Ne, anscheinend geht das nicht.
Ah, Moment, der Collector, das hier alles in Rows.
Der collecte das hier ja alles in Rows.
Das heißt, ich muss...
die...
Row...
Ähm...
Header?
So was wie first
Border geht net
Die die row brauch auch jetzt
Also quasi header 1 oder so oder header 0
darf man hat wie mache ich das jetzt gescheit weil hier unten
moment moment das muss ich mal kurz let's go gleich
Das sind jetzt hier die...
So was kann man doch machen.
Das müsste doch im Prinzip...
ähnlich sein, oder?
Warte mal, jetzt benennen wir das mal Header.
Teil
So, da können wir uns nämlich
diesen ganzen Kram hier sparen. Mal gucken, wie es aussieht.
Okay, richtig. So, und da
gibt es jetzt kein
Da gibt es jetzt kein Border, oder was?
Man kann eine Row nicht
Border machen.
Aber Block
Wie war das mit Block nochmal?
Block, irgendwie Block?
block muss man muss man sagen gibt es aber auch nicht ich bin übelst verwirrt
das muss doch gehen man muss doch man muss doch hier in den strich machen
können unter dem unter dem header
hier ist es nicht so ich habe die halt farben
block kann man ein block drum herum machen ja das geht auch wir können
block drum herum machen mein gott macht die beispiele noch nicht so krass kompliziert hat
Block bordert.
Kann ich das irgendwie rappen oder so?
dass man jetzt sagt, let block gleich block new
und wie ging das hier unten jetzt? block bordert, ach so macht man das.
block bordert ok ok ok so aber wie setzt man da jetzt den block
wenn das für das super verwirrend dass das ding zu benutzen
wenn ich jetzt wie kann ich jetzt
Die Tabelle hat Support für Block, Einzelzellen oder Rows anscheinend nicht.
Ja anscheinend nicht.
Und und aber...
Ich hätte jetzt gehofft es gibt hier ein Example drinne.
Ja so kompliziert will ich es ja gar nicht mehr haben.
Ja, das ist das, wie sie es in Zukunft machen wollen.
Okay, wisst ihr was?
Ich frage jetzt mal KI.
Mal gucken.
Ob der irgendwas Sinnvolles einfällt.
und hätte du hast bottom line border only on the bottom science
100 webseiten durchsucht das standard table welche das hat herr für specific
heder border property to achieve border only on the bottom you must use the bottom
margin one method on the row serving as your header
but this creates one row gap which you can style with a border character bottom margin
bottom
bottom margin tatsächlich 1 ok und jetzt jetzt haben wir da schon
und das kann man jetzt steilen irgendwie
setze bottom bottom bottom martin bei die von setzen ist name auf plan klein
Das ist kein Border, ja.
Es geht ja noch weiter.
Ich wollte gerade sagen,
wir können einfach eine Row machen,
die
Ich wollte gerade sagen, eine Row, die halt nur aus Strich
By the way, Rounded Border
Wie geht denn das im Terminal, habt ihr das gerade gesehen?
Wie machen die das?
Irgendwelche krassen UTF-8 Zeichen, oder?
Äh, Unicode Zeichen
Mit den Rounded Border
Das ist doch, das ist doch extrem Six Head
magic
okay das war kurz kurs war jetzt one mt line below the header ja und jetzt weiter
Hä?
Das ist ja eine bescheuerte Antwort, Alter.
Das ist ja richtig dumm.
Das bringt gar nichts.
Ja, Leute, das geht anscheinend nicht.
Da bin ich jetzt aber ein bisschen enttäuscht, ehrlich gesagt,
dass so eine banale Sache wie eine hübsche
Tabelle malen nicht möglich ist.
Wisst ihr, ich will einfach
hier einen Strich drunter.
Was sind denn das überhaupt für Zeichen hier?
Oh, das ist
Special High IQ Zeichen.
Das ist nicht einfach ein Underscore.
Das ist
POC
Unicode Zeichen.
Aber eine eigene Zeile machen, um das reinzuschreiben, das bringt es jetzt ja auch nicht.
Wir können das mal machen, ja, wir können das mal machen.
Vielleicht sieht es halbwegs brauchbar aus.
Ich will jetzt quasi eine row.
Okay, machen wir das nochmal.
mal hier.
Adder.
Splitter.
Wie bei DSL.
Ja, aber das ist ja richtig dumm.
Gibt's nicht?
Weil wenn ich jetzt einfach so mache
Bringt das ja nix
Okay, wenn ich das nur mal so
Exemplarisch, ich nehm mal das jetzt als Header
Da rein
Dann sieht das trotzdem kacke aus
Leute, ich glaube
Ich glaube ernsthaft
Ne hübsche Tabelle
Ist nicht drin
Ich meine, wie kann das sein?
Das kann doch nicht sein. Das ist eine Library mit
17.000 Sternen.
Da muss ich nochmal kurz...
Moment.
Ich kopiere mir das mal.
Moment, wo sind wir denn hier?
Ich kopiere das mal in meine andere KI,
ob die irgendeine Ahnung hat davon.
Warum kann man das nicht kopieren?
Alter.
Schauen wir mal.
Wir schauen mal, was ChatGPT sagt.
So.
Und jetzt gucken wir,
was
GLM 4.7 dazu sagt.
Und wir gucken noch,
wir haben jetzt volle Vibe-Coding-Attacke.
Und wir gucken noch, was
äh
Minimax
ml 2.1 dazu sagt.
Wenn wir es selbst nicht hinkriegen,
dann lassen wir die AI für uns
gucken.
Okay, es denkt. Es denkt, Leute.
Es ist richtig hart am Denken.
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal, was die hier sagen.
Okay.
Aha.
Header, Block, New.
Ah.
Okay.
Das heißt...
Venture.
borders bottom style cray padding horizontal und so immer das genau macht content die methode
gibt es wieder nicht einstellt alter es wäre so eine gute idee gewesen
aber man muss doch man muss doch was in den block retten können
das muss doch funktionieren
aber den header kann ich hier auch gar nicht setzen weil es muss nur sein
es muss nur sein dass frist es funktioniert wieder nicht hat gefällt
content header content das gibt es halt einfach nicht
so aus die sich da wieder ausdenken soll mal gucken mal gucken was was der hier
sagt okay du erde border only an the bottom you can apply a block with border to the head and
row das hat ja kein block die stochert wieder maßlos im dunkeln operation time laut der volt
Context 7 fragen, warum hat er das nicht gemacht?
Ah, ich kann nur, weil ich...
Nö.
Ist es gerade down?
Context 7.
Was ist denn jetzt?
Vielleicht noch irgendein Stream, wo ich nicht unterbrochen werde mit irgendwelchen Plotts.
Das sagt Perplexity, wollen wir auch nochmal gucken. Okay, was sagt Perplexity? Perplexity sagt
using block ok moment table blog geht es das so schlau sind wir selbst dass das
das haben wir selbst hingekriegt ich will ich will den header
ein
der mädchen macht hier überhaupt nichts mit dem header
und hätte hat das wie wir wissen oder schon gesehen haben hat hätte er hat
kein blog gibt es nicht kann auch nicht importieren
ich glaube einfach nicht dass das
Ja, ja, ich lebe noch.
Ich lebe noch.
Wir hängen jetzt schon ganz schön lang
an sowas simplem fest. Aber das hätte ich nicht gedacht,
dass das so ein Aufriss ist,
eine ordentliche Tabelle hier drinnen zu malen.
Ja, guck.
Die AI halluziniert auch krass
sich hier heftig allen zusammen.
Block new borders bottom. Das ist ja schön, dass es geht, aber der Header hat keine Block-Methode.
Jetzt mal kurz was checken. Ah jetzt ist er connected. Okay. Escape, escape, escape. Jetzt
darf er noch mal und darf auch bei
jetzt es geht
Das ist auch geil.
Use a block on just a header.
Nichts von einem Block zu sehen.
Das hier soll ein Beispiel dafür sein,
aber es ist nichts davon zu sehen.
Ich will unter dem
Header
hier
unter dem Header
Das geht gerade nicht.
Will ich einen Strich haben?
Das soll im Endeffekt so aussehen dann.
Das kann doch nicht sein, dass das nicht geht.
Aber anscheinend geht das nicht.
denn ein playa bottom ball zu der entire block also erstellt kannst ja
gar voll vergessen was hat ein chat gibt jetzt eigentlich gesagt
der hallo zieht sich schon auch was zusammen
ok ok also sagt gpt
das ignoriert das einfach
Der denkt, ich will meine Tabelle...
Ich glaube einfach, das geht nicht.
Und das nervt mich jetzt schon wieder, dass ich die Tabelle nicht so schön machen kann, wie ich will.
Ha! Chat-GPT-Kack-Wait, Alter!
Ja, mit sowas kannst du halt KI-Sachen vergessen, ne?
Dann sagen wir ihm mal...
There is no function.
Jetzt guckt er nochmal mit.
Correct!
Okay, okay, was kommt jetzt?
Jetzt macht er einfach gar nichts.
Headerblock, okay.
Ah, was macht der denn da?
Das ist vielleicht gar nicht so blöd
Der rendert erstmal die Tabelle ohne, warum auch immer
Und dann
Ne, das ergibt auch keinen Sinn
Na wobei
Ey so blöd ist die Idee gar nicht
Der rendert zu ersten Strich
Und dann rendert er die Tabelle
Das ist gar nicht so blöd glaube ich
wartet mal
das checken wir jetzt mal kurz ob das so funzt
erst erst den kompens macht dem erst mal zu
was
Äh
Ne
Was, okay
Was passiert denn, was passiert denn
Wenn ich die Tabelle nicht rendere
Macht das überhaupt irgendwas
Ah
Ne, dann von
Das ist ja ein Kampf
Probier mal das hier
Wenn ich jetzt debadet, wenn ich das aufmach
Nee, werde ich nicht.
Also, was machst du hier?
Space between header...
Rows?
Wie?
Und was...
Das macht doch nix.
Was?
Da ist doch nichts dabei, was hier irgendwas damit zu tun hat. Wir wollen ja den Header explizit
ordern und nicht die ganze Tabelle.
Das habe ich doch gerade mehr oder weniger schon genauso.
Ich habe doch einen Header, das ist eine Row wie bei dir und dann habe ich die ganze
bordertabelle das ist doch das ist doch mehr oder weniger genau das was du auch hast sagt jeminal
jeminal ist genauso blöd weiß es auch nicht besser tja das scheint nicht zu funktionieren
ich bin verwirrt das ist aber echt doof ich habe ja gedacht dass also das was chat gpt
gemacht hat ist noch am nächsten dran ja funzt funzt net ganz richtig ja aber würde
kommt kann man eigentlich hier unten drunter noch mal einen print print line oder so machen
dass der Uline macht. Ne, macht er nicht. Also ChatGPT ist ja da prinzipiell gar nicht so
verkehrt. Das rendert quasi was. Kann man das vielleicht so machen? Erst das und dann das.
Ja, also das ist gar nicht so blöd hier. Problem ist nur, dass es das nicht hier oben rendern kann.
sondern sonst wo das regert mich hart ey leute dass ich dich wir sind jetzt schon eine stunde
an tabelle malen aber das trägt mich wirklich hat dass ich nicht so eine popliche tabelle malen kann
Hallo.
Ich wollte ja noch mehr machen.
Aber eine Tabelle? Ich will eine Tabelle haben.
Und Tabelle geht nicht.
Das ist aber echt
dumm.
Ich meine, was wir mal
probieren könnten...
Also das hier
funzt ja offensichtlich
nett.
Was wir da haben...
Was wir mal probieren könnten
ist...
Warte mal, machen wir mal hier kurz das wieder weg.
also anstatt nur mal so testweise
also wenn man jetzt hier
hier drinnen, kann man hier drinnen einen Block
rendern, kann man hier einen Block
Block
innenblock
überall nicht, gibt's nicht
aber sowas geht doch hier, Block
Rust verwirrt mich.
Block Border, das will ich doch haben.
Warum zeigst du mir das hier nicht an?
Ach, weil ich Mist importiert habe.
Nice Rust-Fehlermeldung.
Es muss Text sein, oder was?
Es muss Text sein.
Also man kann jetzt in die Zelle nicht einfach einen Block reinpappen oder wie.
Hm.
Es scheint nicht, das Leutest scheint nicht zu gehen.
Ganz wir.
Kannst du eine Zeile in einen Block packen?
Nee.
Das geht nicht, weil Table will unbedingt eine Row haben.
Ich habe jetzt versucht, einen Block in eine Row zu packen.
Aber das geht auch nicht.
Also nee, ich habe versucht, quasi einen Block hier in eine Zelle zu packen, aber...
Zeile geht auch nicht.
Zeile wäre das hier.
die Tabelle, die möchte hier unbedingt
möchte die
Rows haben.
Guck, es muss Rows sein.
Könnte man, okay, wir können mal
eins probieren, anstatt Rows, wir machen jetzt
einfach hier Block.
Aber
ich weiß noch nicht mal, wie man in den Block
Achso, wenn ich es richtig schreiben würde.
Gut.
Ich weiß nicht mal, wie ich in den Block jetzt gescheit
Block
Bordert
Ich weiß jetzt nicht mal, wie ich in den Block jetzt überhaupt
Was richtig rappen würde
Gucken wir mal kurz hier, Widgets Block
Ja, und wie macht man Inhalt in den Blog rein?
Also das ist nicht sonderlich intuitiv zu benutzen, muss ich sagen.
Blog with Content.
Wie kriegt man Content in den Blog rein?
Wollt ich vielleicht mal in ein Tutorial gucken?
Schauen wir mal kurz hier, da gibt es doch so gibt es doch Examples.
showcase apps
Wir hatten doch hier die hat noch hier examples erstens wo ihr examples apps
Demo
Alter jetzt aber zu übertreiben
Man kann das immer nur auf den Widget selbst setzen.
Das ist aber eine komische Logik.
Also man setzt quasi das Parent-Widget auf dem Unter-Widget.
Das ist irgendwie sehr merkwürdig.
Normalerweise würde ich erwarten, dass es dann Block gibt.
Und da gibt es dann Content.
Und da packt man das irgendwie Set-Content.
Und da packt man dann das nächste rein oder so.
Aber das Rohr ist komisch.
Listening, Leute.
Listening.
I want a row inside a block.
Inno!
Leute, also ich weiß nicht.
Diese Library ist mir viel zu
Pfeifert zu benutzen.
Findet das
Findest irgendjemand intuitiv?
Ich weiß nicht.
Nee.
Komm, wir probieren mal was anderes.
Wir probieren mal was anderes.
17.000 Sterne lügen nicht.
Ja, aber das...
Nee.
Machen wir das gerade mal wieder.
Guck mal, ob wir noch irgendwas hier finden in dem...
Das ist offen seit 2023.
The fuck?
Was jetzt gegen Richass sprach, dass es sieben Sterne hat und vielleicht vibe-coded ist.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Ich glaube, ich verstehe jetzt, warum man den Block an die einzelnen Widgets pappen muss.
Weil es ist eine Terminal Library, da macht das durchaus Sinn.
Weil ein Border ist ja nichts, was quasi dann erst Inhalt gemalt wird, dann Border gemalt wird.
Sondern das muss ja quasi mit Zeichen passieren.
Da brauchst du Padding links und rechts und sowas.
Brauchst ein bisschen Ahnung vom Inhalt eventuell.
Was schaust du gerade so für Serien, Animes?
Nix, nix.
Okay, Leute, aber Hauptsache...
Hauptsache, man kann sowas hier machen, aber keine richtige Tabelle.
Chat, was findet ihr wichtiger? Eine ordentliche Tabelle oder sowas?
Also ich bin ja dafür eine ordentliche Tabelle.
So was ist auch nicht verkehrt, aber eine ordentliche Tabelle wäre schon nice.
Ganz klar.
Aber das geht anscheinend wirklich nicht.
Also da bin ich jetzt echt enttäuscht, dass so ein basic Ding wie eine Tabelle nicht funktioniert.
Also weiter.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier Schönes?
Das kopiere ich mir mal
Also, das hätten wir noch
Wir hätten
Ich habe noch mehrere Sachen gefunden
Ridge RS
Wo man hier crates
Ridge
Ja, und das noch.
Also, wir hätten hier ein paar andere Libraries zur Auswahl.
Einmal das da.
Rustport of Pythons Popular Ridge Library.
Und Ridge AS.
Das Ding ist nur...
Das ist bestimmt einfach nur
Vibe-Coded und Funst nicht richtig.
Ich hab die gleiche Playlist einfach
laufen hier.
Das ist eine Playlist, die geht eineinhalb Stunden.
Können was anderes anmachen.
Cloud ist sogar Contributor? Wo hast du das gesehen?
Ach nee, kurzer Sinn.
Ach, bei ihm hier, oder was?
Wenn das nicht Vibe-Coded ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Das ist halt das Ding.
Du weißt heute bei neuen Projekten halt nicht,
ob es irgendwelcher Vibe-Coded Shit ist.
Okay, ich habe eine Idee.
Ich habe eine Idee, wie wir das rauskriegen.
Alter, GitHub, nerv mich doch jetzt nicht.
Wir haben ja auch so viele Requests gemacht.
ich habe eine idee wie wir das rauskriegen wir gehen jetzt einfach mal an anfang
und schauen mal wie das aussieht
das ist generiert leute das ding
das sieht doch schon dass das sieht das ist doch komplett
AI, Alter.
Meine Güte, ey.
Gibt es nix in Rust,
was schöne
Command-Line-Anwendungen machen kann,
was auch Tabellen malen kann.
Das ist alles AI-Stellsel.
Das ist auch...
RichAS hat schon Cloud-Code in den Contributors drin.
Ich will nichts Vibe-Codedes.
Nee.
Mach ich nicht.
Verwende ich nicht.
Das kann durchaus sein, dass es für die Basic-Sachen funktioniert.
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Was war das andere? Comfy Table.
Build beautiful terminal table with automatic...
Ja, genau. Sowas hier. Sowas will ich haben. Comfy Table.
Das klingt doch gut.
Ey, das hat ja sogar mal eine
API, die man halbwegs checkt.
Kann man
vielleicht das...
Okay.
Wir hatten da doch auch irgendwas gepostet.
Für Table.
Was da? Tabled.
Hier haben wir auch noch was.
Also wir haben
Comfy Table.
Comfy Table oder
Tablet.
Nehmen wir mal Tablet.
Boah.
Alter, wie viele
Examples. Krass.
WTF.
Heftig.
So, mal gucken, ob er das jetzt gescheit verwenden kann.
Hier.
Weil ich meine,
vielleicht können wir ja
Ratatouille benutzen für eine Progress Bar.
Das wollte ich nämlich auch noch machen.
Eine Progress Bar.
Und dieses Ding hier nehmen wir dann halt, bis es unterstützt für Tabellen.
Based on String is active true?
Was?
Based on?
Das ist schon wieder eine Syntax, die gefällt mir nicht.
Markdown?
Wir probieren das jetzt mal
Colored Borders, das klingt doch gut
Ach, das hier oben ist ein Struct
Ah, jetzt verstehe ich das
Okay, interesting
Nehmen wir das mal, wir kopieren das jetzt einfach mal hier rein
Machen wir mal...
Draw, machen wir mal weg.
Ja.
Draw. Kommt einfach weg, dann passiert auch nichts.
Zack.
Dann kopieren wir uns...
Ich bin verwirrt.
Dann kopieren wir uns mal hier nochmal das Strukt.
Tables brauchen wir.
Genau, Tables.
Tablet.
Sehr schlau hier.
Er sagt
0.20 ist die aktuellste Version
Ja, habe ich, habe ich
Das kenne ich
Ja, ja, das habe ich mitbekommen
Der hatte da noch einen Klarstellungspost gemacht danach
Äh, Moment, Moment, Moment
0.17
Und hier haben wir angeblich 20
Ist das was anderes?
Okay, gibt es kein GitHub Tag für, meinetwegen.
Okay.
Style muss weg.
Tablet
Und Color muss auch weg
Das ist ja eklig, das kann man jetzt
Da müssen wir
Warte mal
Das muss man so sagen
Tablet
Color
Wo kommt denn das her?
Tablet
Color
ETF
Wo ist denn hier
dieser scheiß Color Typ?
Na gut, dann schmeißen wir den hier raus.
import.
Wo kam der her?
Tablet Settings.
Okay, die zwei
Frameworks beißen sich gerade ein bisschen.
Tablet.
Okay, gut.
Haben wir hier noch einen Fehler?
Weil Color, ja, ja.
Okay, Cargo, Run.
Ich glaube, wir schmeißen dieses
Gratatui-Zeug schon mal wieder raus hier.
Weil der macht hier oben ja auch
Init
Ah ja, jetzt schon besser
Ja
So kann
Eine Tabelle aussehen, ja
So einfach könnte es sein
Machen wir doch mal was anderes
Machen wir mit der Tabelle so, wie ich es eigentlich haben wollte
Erstmal gucken, wie macht man überhaupt
den Border-Style hier drinnen.
Guck mal, hier kann man sogar
Corners und alles setzen.
Das ist richtig nice.
Wie kann man jetzt den Typ einstellen,
welche Striche
wie die Borders gemalt werden sollen.
Border.
Remove Border. Set Border.
Set Borders.
Und da kann man jetzt einstellen,
mit welchem Charakter er das macht, oder wie?
Guck mal, man kann ja auch für andere...
Hier ist Style...
Ah, so geht das.
Style Modern, Style Extended.
Ah, so, okay, okay, verstehe.
Ja, das sieht doch jetzt mal nach einer ordentlichen Tabelle aus, oder?
Das geht doch voll klar.
So, jetzt hätte ich nur noch gerne,
dass nur, dass das hier
keine, dass das hier keinen Style mehr hat.
So einfach nur
hier oben so.
Könnte man das machen?
Style, remove borders.
Okay, dann ist das wahrscheinlich keine gute Idee.
Dann ist alles weg.
Ja.
Remove
borders bottom.
Okay.
Boah, das geht da mit wahrscheinlich auch nicht richtig, oder?
Aber immerhin schon mal deutlich besser als das andere.
Vorher noch ein paar Examples.
Ja doch, im Prinzip so wie das hier.
Haben die bei den Examples Bilder dabei?
Ah ja.
Ja, das ist doch gut hier.
Table.
Ja, Bilder.
Genau so will ich es haben.
Nur hier oben den Header.
Und dann...
Ja, so ist das gut.
Color.
Äh, hallo?
Hallo?
ein bisschen doof dass es das beispiel nicht mehr gibt was es angeblich hier
gibt schon wieder ppg auch zehn aber gut hast du ein style
das ist wenigstens übersichtlich hier style modern hier kann es sagen
remove horizontal remove vertical ok table alignment center
weiß ich nicht
eine moderne
Im Moment das... einfach so.
Theme brauchen wir ja nicht.
Style.
So ne?
Ey, das ist immer auch ein bisschen eklig zu checken.
Was der da immer für Imports will.
So, was haben wir jetzt?
Wie sieht es jetzt aus?
Ja!
Easy!
Genau so.
So will ich die Tabelle haben.
So soll die aussehen.
Sehr gut.
Nach drei Stunden gefühlt haben wir eine Tabelle.
So, und jetzt kommt das nächste.
Progress Bar.
Dafür brauchen wir jetzt natürlich wieder
dann doch das andere Tool, ja.
Wenn ich das hier mache, dann geht aber die andere Tabelle nicht mehr.
Sobald ich das hier mache, backt die Tabelle rum.
Das ist halt scheiße.
Dann muss ich zuerst die Tabelle malen.
Muss ich zuerst die Tabelle malen und dann darf ich...
Ach fuck, das macht es dann auch kaputt, oder was?
Das verträgt sich nicht miteinander.
Kann man da einfach...
Also ganz ehrlich, das ist ja abfuck.
Hübsche Rust-CLI-Programme zu erstellen.
Also ich meine, wenn ich jetzt nur für die Tabelle was hätte benutzen müssen.
Okay, aber das zerstört ja den Tabellen... oder auch nicht.
Wie jetzt?
Jetzt doch nicht?
Ne, geht doch.
Hä? Okay.
Also das von uns.
Man muss zuerst die Tabelle
printen und dann kann man den anderen
Kram benutzen. Okay.
Schön ist echt was anderes.
Was natürlich cool wäre,
wenn hier Ratatouille
das unterstützen würde,
dass man
quasi escaped was
inserten kann in so ein Widget
und dass der dann nicht anfasst.
Aber gut.
Jetzt versuchen wir mal eine Progress Bar zu malen.
Also wir haben eine Tabelle.
Wir haben eine Tabelle am Start.
Oh, jetzt sagen wir Draw.
Draw.
So, jetzt mal nochmal eine zweite eklige Tabelle.
Aber die Tabelle, wir malen jetzt ja gar keine Tabelle mehr.
Weg damit.
Machen wir mal.
Okay, wie machen wir eine Progress Bar?
Gibt es jetzt hier Progress?
Hm.
Wie könnte man eine Progress Bar machen?
Bar Chart?
Schon, aber nicht.
wirklich oder? Chat?
Ja, das ist ja alles super schön und fancy,
aber ich will eine Progress Bar malen.
Gautsch.
Ah, okay.
Gautsche.
Ah.
Aber schön ist auch was anderes.
Was ist das?
Wisst ihr, was ich gerne hätte?
So was.
Eine Progress Bar daneben.
Mich wundert es, dass es so eine Library
nicht geben soll für Rust.
Das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen.
Also Ratatouille und so, das mag ja ganz okay sein,
wenn man Fullscreen-Konsolenanwendungen bauen will.
War so?
Stimmt.
Ach, du meinst, man braucht in Rust gar keine Progressbar,
weil es so blazingly fast ist.
Stimmt, stimmt.
Jetzt.
Jetzt, wo du es sagst.
Jetzt macht es Sinn.
Ja.
Indikativ.
Rust.
Ja, das macht jetzt aber wiederum nur Progress Bars.
Ich will doch nicht eine Library haben für Tabellen
Eine für Progress Bars
Eine für Textformatting
Eine für
Color Highlight
Einer für Spinner
Ja, das ist schön, das gefällt mir
Aber das kann doch nicht sein
Dass ich jetzt irgendwie 8 Libraries verwenden muss
Ich bin verwöhnt von Spectre, Console & Ridge
Ja gut, aber
Warum hat Trust sowas nicht?
Was ist doch Blazingly Fast und die ganzen neuen coolen Leute verwenden Rust.
Das finde ich übrigens sehr hübsch hier.
Gefällt mir richtig gut.
Das gefällt mir richtig gut.
Genauso stelle ich mir das vor.
Weil ganz ehrlich, das Ding hier will ich nicht.
Das will ich nicht unbedingt bei mir im Terminal hier haben.
Das sieht ja nicht hüpfend aus.
Keine Spinner?
Spinner?
Oh, ja, was ist das denn hier?
Das brauche ich.
imaged.
Bubblety ist ähnlich bloated wie Ratatouille.
Ja, damit wollte ich auch mal in Zukunft was machen.
Ist das genauso eklig?
Weniger eklig.
Da muss man doch gerade mal kurz gucken.
Table.
Ich will einfach nur mal kurz...
Hat es keine Tables?
Hat es erst gar keine Tables eingebaut, oder was?
Gibt es da ein Example für?
Die haben erst gar keine Hilfeseite, oder wie?
Wie soll man das dann benutzen?
examples
table
ich sehe schon, komm, das kann man auch nicht richtig stylen
na gut, immerhin, das kann man noch halbwegs lesen
border style border bottom okay immerhin immerhin kannst du hier den header ordentlich stylen
das schon mal deutlich besser richtig richtig schön sieht aus aber immerhin immerhin das ist
gar nicht so schlimm.
Ratatouille hat anscheinend auch keine Spinner
oder sowas. Ja, was ist das?
Warum hat das denn 17... Als Ernst gemeint?
Warum hat das denn 17.000 Sterne?
Du kannst keine Spinner auf der
Kommandozeile machen. Du hast keine gescheite Progress Bar.
Die Table suckt.
Warum hat das 17.000 Sterne?
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Das muss dann für Fullscreen-Terminal-Anwendungen richtig geil sein.
Ansonsten kann ich mir das nicht erklären.
Ja, das hier, das ist nice, das gefällt mir.
Aber ich finde es halt ein bisschen doof, dass ich ein Library brauche für Progress Bar,
für Table, für irgendwie ordentliche
Spinner, für
Textformatierung, Highlighting
und das ist doch
äh
Wir müssen halt drei verschiedene oder fünf verschiedene
Libraries benutzen
Deswegen habe ich eigentlich gedacht, das hier ist hier
The Way
Ja
Dachte ich
dass das der Weg ist.
Aber ist es nicht.
Ne.
Ne, ich weiß nicht.
Ich bin gerade echt zu überlegen,
will ich wirklich Kommandozeilen
Sachen mit
mit die dann halt auch komando zahl also komando zahlen viel komando zahlen output ist das wirklich
in rast machen ich bin da gerade echt so ein bisschen am überlegen wir können doch mal hier
eine progress bar machen ich benutze x vibe code das mit sieben stern wer weiß wie das so portet
ist er weiß was das für edge cases hat wo es wieder nicht funktioniert aber nur so aussieht als ob
Microsoft ist auch Vibe Coded.
Ja und das siehst du ja an der Qualität von Windows.
Das fühlt sich auch so an als wäre es Vibe Coded.
Ok wir probieren das jetzt hier trotzdem aus.
Download RSExample.
Wenigstens ein schön kurzes
Exempel. Das ist doch nice.
Okay, Ratatouille
schmeißen wir erstmal wieder raus. Zack.
Weg. Weg.
Weg.
So, jetzt haben wir nur noch unsere Tabelle übrig.
Die wenigstens optisch
ganz gut ausschaut.
So, und jetzt können wir hier
progress bar
ok, das
das sind doch mal gute Beispiele hier
die sind schön self-contained
da erkennt man was
und jetzt muss ich, wie heißt
dieses Ding hier, Indicative
aber du benutzt es, ja, bleibt damit nicht viel alles übrig
Ich würde auch was anderes benutzen.
Aha.
Gucken, ob die Idee schlau genug ist.
Das ist wirklich 1,18.
Ja, ist tatsächlich so.
Ja doch, doch, da habe ich eine Auswahl
Da benutze ich einfach nicht Rust
Ganz einfach
Progress Bar
Progress Style
Progress State
Alter, was ist das für eine Syntax
W und Mut
Dünn Right
Okay, Rust Logik, das bedeutet
Was ist das richtige?
I.O.?
Das bedeutet, alles was den Ride-Trade implementiert und davon eine mutable Reference.
Das ist halt auch Caché-Syntax.
Was hat er für Schmerzen?
Okay, dann war das doch das andere Ride.
Dann war das doch das andere Ride.
Dann war ein Standard-FMT-Ride.
Min.
Red Sleep.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Tokyo.
Time.
Sleep.
So.
Wie lange sleept der hier?
12 Millisekunden.
Ah, so geht's.
Ach.
So und jetzt kriegen wir eine schöne Progress Bar oder wie?
Oh, massive Progress Leiste.
Die sieht fast aus wie die Specter Console Progress Bar.
Machen wir es mal ein bisschen kürzer hier, 10 Millisekunden.
Das ist ein schönes Crate, easy und sieht hübsch aus.
Das gefällt mir.
Ich finde es aber immer noch blöd, dass ich nicht All-in-One haben kann.
Ja, doch.
So, also ich brauche nicht wirkliche Progress Bar eigentlich.
Also, ich wollte einfach nur gucken, wie es funktioniert.
So, ähm, dann können wir doch jetzt mal versuchen, was Sinnvolles zu machen.
Schmeißen wir die Progress Bar Geschichte mal wieder weg.
So, hier haben wir die Tabelle, die geprintet wird.
Im Prinzip ja auch genauso, wie wir das haben wollen.
Ich rufe jetzt mal Domaininfos ab und dann schreibe ich die in die Tabelle rein.
Das probieren wir jetzt einfach mal aus.
Also, wie machen wir das?
Lass mal kurz überlegen.
Erstmal müssen wir ja die Domaininfos abrufen.
Wir rufen hier ab per AirDub.
guck da machen was habe ich ja gerade schon gezeigt da war sowas wie hier
wo bloß wo bloß punkt tv und da kriegen wir so infos waren das expired und so
frage ist nur wie mache ich das in rust kann man da web requests machen dagegen
darf man da web requests dagegen machen
bestimmt nicht oder das finden die bestimmt doof
gibt es ein erdap sein für rust gibt es sogar official kann implementierung
guck mal hier malen sie auch tabellen
im prinzip wollte ich sowas hier wollte ich sowas hier hier bauen so was ähnliches nur
dass es halt nicht dass nur auf kommando zeile ausgibt sondern auch für monitoring tools das
verwertbar macht.
Hier haben wir eine Library.
Gibt es da nicht vielleicht was, wo man
Adopt Jason?
Wo man da mit Curl
irgendwie curlen kann?
Achso, ah, Moment, man kann das...
Ja, dann, da brauche ich doch da kein Client für.
Guck mal, da kann ich das einfach curlen.
Easy.
Ja.
Curl, Domain, Woblords.tv, gepiped nach JQ.
Was?
Achso, wir sind in der VM.
Ach, deswegen ist kein JQ drin.
Aber das brauchen wir.
Das muss auf jeden Fall,
wo wir gerade dabei sind,
das muss auf jeden Fall in meine Base
Base Images
rein.
Docker File Base
Install
jq.
Unbedingt.
So, guck.
Und jetzt haben wir hier
Zeug.
krass das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf
alter, ok was kriegen wir
jetzt hier für Antworten, domain wubblos.tv
status active
expiration
das interessiert mich
entities
version text, was hab ich, alter was ist
denn hier noch alles drin
das brauchen wir alles gar nicht
achso das sind jetzt die Sachen wie technischer
Ansprechpartner und sowas
arbeitest du jetzt noch in dev container aber wenn ich was entwickeln war ich das
nur in dev container und die rest mache ich hier in der normalen shell aber wenn ich bin
ich wenn das entwickeln wir macht es nur in dev container einfach weil ich dann gegen ganze
supply chain angriffe nicht mit nicht mehr so anfällig bin die domains gehen die domains ist
wieder eine ausnahme des fonds nicht die domains musst du den erdab vom denig verwenden dann geht
das guck kannst du hier den ich stehe nicht stellt machen als die hier ausführen domain beispiel und
da kannst du zum beispiel sagen max fps punkt de kriegst du auch so was leider kriegt es bei
die domains kein exp date
so als muss ich mal kurz gucken was habe ich denn ich habe doch letztens
mal mit rust
ein
so so api sachen abgerufen das ding hieß request hieß das request mit w request
war kurz in meine cargo tommel
request das hier hatte ich
wasser genau das war voll durch die brust ins auge wieder wie man das
verwenden muss man muss sich hier sagen wie christ version features jason und
rast pls weil ansonsten will dann ein statisch kompiliertes open ssl haben
wenn er sieht der wenn er dabei durch statisch kompiliert also dass dann x
was ist hier die letzte die neueste gibt es drei agos gibt sogar 13.1 schon
ich outdated war ich da bild fällt es nicht ob das feld ist okay dann wollen
wir doch mal ab eine abfrage machen also welche also das da zum beispiel dass da
war jetzt mal abfrage wie das guck mal wie das wie das genau von starbucht
lassen lasst mich noch mal kurz nachgucken wie das ging ich hatte ja hier
so ein beispiel source api request okay so muss man das machen also was sie
Genau, und get.
Ähm, get.
Domain.
Info.
Äh, nee, nee, nee. Underscore.
So.
Alter.
Ähm, so.
Und da wollen wir jetzt...
Wie ging das jetzt nochmal? Lass mich mal kurz gucken.
Also, wir brauchen eine URL.
Set URL gleich.
Haben wir hier
wieder
Oh.
Ah, ne.
So, URL. Und dann konnte man
sagen
Client
Ah ja, Request
Default
Den sollte man dann am besten zwischenspeichern
Äh, Client
Aber jetzt, wenn wir hier, Client
Dann kann man sagen, Client
Get
Genau, ungefähr so
Ungefähr so
Ähm
unten können wir ok zurückgeben
alles klar
so url
example.com
machen wir mal wubblords.tv
hier übergeben wir noch
einen String
wobei eigentlich
eigentlich war bei keinem String gegeben
sondern ein Strill
äh ne ein und und und Strill
gibt es eigentlich auch so strill und und und und strill domain in dem moment
wir sind in rust so rum ist mein rust unterwegs und jetzt können wir sagen
mal hier url url
als das da
fragezeichen
hast du das gesehen max
Nvidia to bring back...
Moment, was?
Nvidia to bring back the GeForce
to tackle...
Ernsthaft?
Ne 3060.
Wie ist die so für AI-Sachen?
Die unterstützen auch SLI, oder?
Kann die nicht auch SLI?
die 3.000er Serie noch?
Da kommen die Leute
dann um die Ecke und machen SLI
mit 4 Stück für AI-Gram.
Ah, es wird teuer, wenn das viel RAM hat.
So, und jetzt weiter.
Base ist das Base-URL.
Jetzt wollen wir Let-URL
gleich BaseJoin
Domain. So wollen wir das haben.
Jetzt haben wir nämlich hier hinten dynamisch
unsere Domain dran. Müssen wir das noch weg machen.
So,
Requestings. Das müsste jetzt eigentlich
funktionieren. Jetzt kriegen wir hier
unsere Domain-Informationen zurück.
Wir müssen die allerdings
JSON parsen.
Sonst
wird das nichts. Lass uns gerade mal
kurz checken.
tracing info nicht domain einmal mit wie salt
so gucken wir mal was da rauskommt hago run
Wow.
Was?
Äh.
Muss man da...
Haben sie was geändert?
Ach, muss man einfach nur noch Rust TLS schreiben jetzt?
Okay, vorher war es Rust TLS TLS.
Jetzt ist es nur noch Rust TLS.
So, Funsters?
Postchamp?
Äh, achso, Alter, bin ich doof.
Ich habe ja sogar vergessen, das aufzurufen.
Also, machen wir hier sowas wie get.
Domain Info.
Was? Table?
Oblos.
Punkt TV.
So, jetzt aber.
Da haben wir es doch.
Ne.
Einmal Curl.
Sekunde.
Mit Curl gibt es das.
Was macht der Minus L?
Mach dein Curl minus groß L.
Location.
Achso, ja gut.
Curl User Agent.
Was für einen User Agent benutzt Curl eigentlich?
Also ich meine,
wir können
curl-user-agent setzen oder wir sagen
accept, dass wir den
accept-Header setzen, dass wir nur noch
Jason accepten.
Aber kann er
einen User-Agent?
Kann man da keinen User-Agent
setzen?
Weg West set user agent
Auto customer ist user agent strings ist auch wieder das auch wieder ein
Generated artikel oder
Client bilder
Es wäre sonst so einfach client bilder
custom user agent gut weil ich habe das gefühl wenn der köln als user agent
drin steht kommt auch als kommt auch als jason zurück ja so sollte das eigentlich
nicht sein wir machen wir machen das korrekt wir waren das korrekt er wäre
wir tun trotzdem so als sind wir köln dass das sind da sind viele crawler
freundlicher so. Wenn man so tut,
dann ist man ein Curl.
Aber
wie setzt man denn jetzt hier bei
dieser ganzen Geschichte eigentlich
ein?
Except Header.
Header? Ah,
Headers.
Kann man das sagen? Except?
Ah ja, gut.
Except
header jason die mussten das aussehen einfach application scheiß jason
application jason so und jetzt gucken wir mal
domain champ fragt an ob jetzt auch jason ist in der rückgabe ok
Rust
Domain
Champ
Okay, Funst
Ich will, pass auf, gleich werden wir rate limited oder sowas
Also mit der Anfrage Funst das hier
Und jetzt müssen wir uns den Name
Jetzt brauchen wir
Okay, jetzt brauchen wir einen Jason
Was
Curl
Jetzt müssen wir einen Struct bauen, wo wir das hier rein serialisieren können.
Das ist natürlich voll eklig.
Es gab doch mal so eine Webseite.
Okay, da können wir jetzt AI für verwenden.
Ich wollte sagen, es gab aber doch mal eine Webseite, die dir für viele Sprachen aus JSON Datentypen zusammenbauen konnte.
Machen wir mal AI Challenge wieder.
Welche AI kriegt es am besten hin?
Ok.
Google AI zuerst.
Ich brauche Rust Structs für diese JSON Response in die ich das rein serialisieren kann.
Mal gucken.
Ah.
Das sieht sogar ganz gut aus, was er hier gebaut hat.
Das sieht sogar ganz brauchbar aus.
Das nehmen wir einfach.
Scheiß drauf.
Passt.
Ja, das nehmen wir.
So, wir lassen mal hier Events.
Status interessiert.
Secure, das juckt mich nicht.
Das juckt mich auch nicht.
Nameservers juckt mich ehrlich gesagt auch nicht.
Das hier auch nicht.
Mein Nameserver.
Was steht denn bei Notices drin?
Ja.
Auch noch JQ.
Was steht denn bei Notice drin?
Kommt das hier links?
Über links kommt das hier.
Notices.
Status.
Status quo.
Okay, das ist quasi ein Help-Text dafür.
Das brauchen wir nicht.
Also das, das, das brauchen wir alles nicht.
Wir brauchen nur noch...
Events.
Events sind noch ganz sinnvoll.
Wo haben wir hier Events?
Da.
Okay.
Ja.
Das war es doch schon.
Da müssen wir gar nicht noch andere AIs damit quälen.
Und jetzt serialisiert man den Kram irgendwie mit Jason.
Wie war das? Jason?
R-Dub-Response.
Macht man das so?
Schauen wir mal.
Cargo run.
Ja!
Das funktioniert doch gut.
Da haben wir es doch hier.
LDH-Name.
Wo steht der LDH?
Domain, Long Domain
Name
Help
Domain Name
Für was steht das H?
Long Domain, Domain
Ach, Händel, Händel
Long Domain Händel
Ich fantasier mir das gerade zusammen
Also nicht, dass ihr denkt, ich wüsste, wofür das steht
So, jetzt haben wir das doch
Sehr schön.
Exzellent.
So, das ist die JSON-Response.
Jetzt holen wir uns aus der JSON-Response
Result.
Events.
Filter. Ich will mir jetzt rausholen.
hier das
Event Action
Expiration
will ich haben.
Also Filter.
Ne, Map.
Map. Oder?
Filter Map.
Glaube ich.
Filter Map war doch glaube ich richtig.
Da kann ich jetzt hier sagen.
Warte mal.
Syntax.
So.
x
Moment.
Fuck, ich weiß gerade die Syntax nicht mehr.
Ich glaube, man kann das komplett weglassen, oder?
Ja, man kann das
komplett
weglassen. Braucht man eigentlich diese
Striche oder kann man auch so hier einfach
machen?
Ne, die Striche brauchen wir.
also jetzt filtern wir hier also das ist ein event event hat event action und date wir suchen
die event action exploration und event date also wir suchen was event action das da hat
Äh
Ich muss eigentlich so sagen
Filter, ne
Filter, genau
Und jetzt nochmal Map
Und jetzt wollen wir Event Date haben
So, und jetzt ist die große Preisfrage.
Wie?
Äh.
Expire.
Expiration Date.
Ups.
Was hat er jetzt für Schmerzen?
Was?
Ah!
Ich muss jetzt irgendwie sagen,
String irgendwas, ne?
String from...
Das muss der ja kopieren.
Das kann man ja nicht moven, das ist ja Rust-Logik.
Genau. Oder auch nicht?
War es toString?
ToString. Genau.
Weil er muss es jetzt kopieren weil es könnte ja sein dass ich den wert später brauche während das hier schon nicht
Mal gültig ist das ist das ist jetzt fast logisch das ist halt das warum rast manchmal auch so eine ganz eklige
Syntax hat war was trades und wehrklausel und alles angeht weil das braucht halt bisschen unterstützung dass das kompilte am checks machen kann
Ok map
Was haben wir das?
Wie mache ich denn jetzt aus einem Date,
wie mache ich denn in Rust aus sowas hier?
Was ist ein...
Was ist ein gutes Time Crate
für Rust?
Vielleicht gibt es auch irgendwas,
was einfach nur Time heißt.
Time. Wow, gut, dann...
Dann ist es auch gut.
examples krono gibt es glaube ich auch gibt keine examples auch sehr gut
sondern example wäre enorm park
Ich würde gern ein Date-Time parsen.
Parse Dates.
Primitive Date-Time
Parse.
Das klingt gut.
Das ist ja auch
in dem Format.
Chat.
Chrono vs. Time.
Guck mal mal.
Create.
Es wird auch so oft benutzt.
Tja.
Example.
Prost, chrono, pass.
Das ist doch bestimmt den UTC, oder?
Weil wenn es nicht in UTC wäre, wäre es echt pepega.
Steht am Ende für UTC, ja.
Also, datetime pass from.
Das sieht doch easy aus.
gleich jawohl das auch 447 ja ich für 42 also warum date time pass also nehmen wir
mal das hier.
Ja, warte mal.
Da brauchen wir jetzt hier so ein...
Also Let.
DateTime.
Pass.
Will er nicht?
Äh.
To.
Str...
Äh, Leute.
Ah, einfach ein Unterform machen.
Okay.
Das verwirrt mich in Rust auch immer.
Es gibt einen String, es gibt einen Unstring,
es gibt einen Unstr...
Gibt's auch ein Str...
Oh, jetzt haben wir das gepasst.
Jetzt wird erstmal unwrapped.
Damit's dann schön crasht,
wenn da was anderes drinsteht.
so und jetzt expiration date über das maus
was da oben habe ich doch gar nichts
was ist denn jetzt los
Was zum
Was ist denn jetzt
Chat was habe ich jetzt kaputt gemacht
Irgendwas habe ich kaputt gemacht
Was
Was zum
Chat
Jetzt müsst ihr mir mal helfen
Was hat er denn jetzt für Schmerzen?
Was will er denn von mir?
Ach, das hier.
Weil er String importiert hat.
Meine Güte, warum macht er denn sowas auch?
Expiration Date.
Zack.
Ah, das darf man nicht
Hat das irgendwie ne
Expiration Date
Map
Moment
Achso, ah, Moment, Moment, Moment
Ich muss das hier erst noch
Ah ne, Moment, wie war das? Collect, gell
Collect
Äh, oh fuck, wie waren da die Syntax?
So
Collect
Und jetzt konnte man irgendwie sagen, weg
Oder?
Und dann Underscore konnte man machen
Oh meine Güte, diese Syntax teilweise
Äh
Chat, jetzt bin ich verpeilt.
Warum ist jetzt hier kein DateTime drin in meinem Vektor?
Warum ist das leer?
Warum ist mein Vektor jetzt leer?
Muss ich dem sagen, dass das ein DateTime
ist, oder was?
Dann check das.
Aber das ist doch abartig.
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Das muss der doch selbst checken.
Okay.
Moment.
True Vector.
Ach, darf man da einfach
nur so Collect?
Darf man da einfach
auch so nur Collect hinschreiben?
Collect?
Ah.
Ne, Type Annotation needed.
Warum?
Warum braucht er eine Type Annotation? Der soll doch wissen, dass das DT ist.
Verstehe ich nicht.
TurboFish Syntax.
Ja, das habe ich doch gerade ausprobiert.
Und das mochte er nicht.
Die TurboFish Syntax.
Moment, jetzt mag er sie?
Chat, was habe ich falsch gemacht vorhin?
Jetzt geht's.
Die TurboFish-Syntax.
Ja.
Ach so, ich hatte hier einen Semikolon dahinter,
deswegen hat das nicht Return.
Jetzt verstehe ich's.
Da lag's an mir.
Und nicht an der TurboFish-Syntax.
TurboFish.
Gut.
jetzt haben wir hier unser expiration date da brauchen wir jetzt irgendwie
den strukt was wir zurückgeben können ob ich kopiere das jetzt einfach mal
ich gesagt reicht mir das wenn man die back haben so domain info heißt es jetzt
einfach nur da haben wir einmal domain string name dann haben wir expire at
Date, Time, Fixed Offset.
Und sonst haben wir nichts.
Wir brauchen auch aktuell nicht.
Status, Status machen wir noch.
Status, Status.
Status.
Events juckt mich jetzt.
status das ist okay so also machen wir jetzt also hier haben wir das result
drin ok also dann geben wir das jetzt zurück und zwar domain info zack domain
name gleich result
Doppelpunkt ist es.
LDH-Name.
Expire-Ad.
Alter, warum macht hier jemand gleich?
Expiration-Date.
Und als letztes Status.
Moment, es gibt mehrere Status, die das haben kann?
Achso, ja gut, da wollen wir nur das erste haben.
was hast du jetzt für schmerzen hier
ach so der sagt ich habe keinen return type hier ein bis alt domain info ok so sollte jetzt funzen
dann machen wir doch hier mal jetzt domain info domain info waren wir noch mal hier in
tracing gehen wir noch mal den kram aus info domain info zack sehr gut genau domain info
domain name expire at status active sehr schön so und jetzt können wir das ganze mal in der
tabelle ausgeben spannend wird das auf die reihe kriegen und dann brauchen wir noch ein paar mehr
Domains. Chat?
Habt ihr noch ein paar Domains, die ich
abfragen soll, wann sie expiren?
Keine DE-Domains?
Dann musst du auch den Denix-Server
anbinden. Ansonsten machen wir die
üblichen Verdächtigen. Facebook, Google, YouTube.
Ah, gegähnt.
Was ist denn das?
Warum steht da eine...
Warum steht da eine Null davor?
Jetzt ist sie weg.
Was war das denn?
Wart ihr das?
Wie viele von euch sind gerade auf dem Heimweg?
Weil der Chat ist unglaublich ruhig für 153 Zuschauer.
Heimweg, Abendessen, irgendwas?
Ich bin da.
Ihr programmiert nebenbei.
Oder du programmierst nebenbei.
Auch krank.
Support-Tickets, na dann.
GLHF.
Also.
Jetzt will ich eine Tabelle malen.
Das kommt weg.
Jetzt Domain-Info.
Editor ist natürlich Blödsinn.
Wir wollen Domain-Info printen.
Data, Domain-Info.
Data geht nicht, weil...
Okay, Editor brauche ich.
Weil Tablet hier fehlt.
Domain-Info.
Tablet.
Okay.
Zeig mal her.
Na.
Das sieht doch schon mal gut aus.
Es kann so easy sein.
Äh, Chat.
Eine Sache, die mich wundert.
Warum ist hier kein Strich?
Warum ist hier kein, kein, nix?
Hier war, achso.
Da ist nie ein Strich.
Nur beim ersten ist ein Strich.
Oh, das ist Pfeifert. Warum?
Next Level Styling.
Wegen Remove Vertical.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Dann machen wir das jetzt einfach hier mehrfach mal rein.
Wobei, das geht ja nicht, ne?
Weil das gemoved ist.
So, jetzt haben wir zweimal das gleiche drin.
So, okay.
Dann machen wir nochmal das, keine Ahnung, google.com.
Youtube.com.
Der Status ist ein bisschen lang, würde ich sagen.
Also der Status ist nicht
Nicht active
So wie es aussieht
Dann müssen wir nochmal hoch
Da wo wir Status
Status uns reinschreiben
Wollen wir nicht
Status join haben, sondern wir wollen
Status, wir nehmen einfach
den ersten Status.
Okay.
Geister Status.
Was ist denn alph.com?
Ah.
Oh, das war eine schlechte Idee,
jetzt einfach eine Domain aus dem Stream einzugeben, Leute.
Jetzt kommen gleich die Boobs hier.
das war es gar nicht probieren ich gebe keine domain mehr aus dem stream jetzt ein
bis drin okay easy
ist das deine domain
Oder wie kommst du da drauf?
Auf die?
Ach, du nimmst die Seite selbst zum Testen, okay.
Ja gut, ähm...
Wir machen jetzt noch ein paar Reihen zum Ausprobieren.
Stück oder so. So, jetzt 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10. So, keine Ahnung. Cloudflare, Cloudflare, Twitch, Twitch TV.
Wann das
expiert.
Mal gucken, ob .NET überhaupt funktioniert.
Amazon.
Ja, vielleicht noch ein paar nicht
Comdomains.
Ich meine, jetzt keine
XXX-Domains oder so. Das reicht.
Das reicht.
Mal schauen, ob es jetzt nicht sogar abkackt, weil irgendwas abfragen kann.
das funst kann man abfragen sehr schön excellent jetzt müssen wir machen jetzt
noch was wir hatten doch ein freund progress progress ding gemalt wir machen jetzt noch
mal eine Progress Bar.
Download
RS.
Hier.
Progress Bar. New Total
Size.
Keine Ahnung. 100.
Ich will eine Progress Bar machen.
Guck mal.
Das dauert jetzt ja eine Weile, bis die Abfragen durch sind.
Ich hätte gerne eine Progress Bar.
Zwischen den Abfragen.
Oder so insgesamt eine Progress Bar.
Dass die da läuft.
Ein Spinner reicht, hast du recht.
Aber ich weiß nicht, wie man da nur einen Spinner machen kann.
Wahrscheinlich einfach...
Ah, doch, einfach so wahrscheinlich.
Einfach nur Spinner,
Green und den Rest
schmeißen wir weg.
Einfach nur Spinner.
Rest brauchen wir wahrscheinlich gar nicht.
Und wie...
Und wie sagen wir dem jetzt, dass es Progress gibt?
Mal kurz was ausprobieren.
Einfach von dem Example hier nochmal.
Tokio
Time Sleep
10 Millisekunden
Macht der jetzt was?
Aha, okay, okay, okay, okay
Also im Endeffekt braucht man bloß hier
Set Position
Also eigentlich
kann man das eigentlich kann man das fähigen also hat man braucht irgendeine geschichte geht
nicht anders aber wir können jetzt hier einfach sagen weil 1 kleiner 100 wir müssen es dann von
hand abrecht das ist ja immer true und jetzt sagen wir set position 1 mal gucken ob es dann
updated wenn man es immer auf einsetzen ja update ok gut dann machen wir das doch mal
einem eigenen red weil wir wollen ja in der zeit was was downloaden während das spin hat
also zack
Was wird gemacht?
Eigentlich soll ich nur gucken, wie man hübsche Rust-Kommandozeilenprogramme macht.
Und wir bauen was,
so ein Kommandozeilenzool,
zum Checken, wann Domains ablaufen.
Kommt mal wieder in Battlefield-Stelz.
Ich müsste erstmal Battlefield 6 spielen.
Aber ich habe meinen Rechner neu installiert,
damit ich Battlefield 6 spielen kann.
Nee, du kannst ruhig auf...
Ihr könnt immer off-topic.
So Sachen zwischendurch.
Chat, eigentlich müssten wir es...
Streng genommen müssten wir es doch so machen.
Wie kann man das denn canceln?
Hier, finish with message.
Also eigentlich...
Wir bräuchten sowas wie ein Cancellation Token.
Also was ich jetzt machen will im Endeffekt ist sowas wie Tokyo, spawn.
Jetzt können wir mit Tokio Select irgendwie machen.
Also was ich machen will, ist folgendes.
Tokio spawn.
Und dann...
...das da rein.
Das geht jetzt irgendwie nicht.
Warum?
äh async
Was habe ich verkehrt gemacht? Async so? Wie ist die richtige Syntax für?
Bin da zu dumpf
Wie ist die richtige Syntax dafür? Tokyo spawn
Aha, so rum.
Ach, so ging das. Okay, ist gut.
Dann, na.
Okay, gut.
So, jetzt wird es gleich
Lifetime-Probleme geben.
Oh.
Ich meine, im Prinzip macht er jetzt das, was er soll, aber das ist definitiv nicht schön.
Das ist definitiv nicht schön.
Weil da könnte ja noch ein bisschen mehr danach jetzt kommen.
Du könntest ja auch sowas machen wie Let's Task Vector Do Work Results Joint.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Also woran ich gedacht habe, ist, dass ich Tokyo Select mache.
Gibt es sowas?
Join all?
Tokyo, join all?
Nee, gibt es nicht.
Tokyo hat sowas nicht.
Was macht der hier?
Der händelt es.
Achso, der
evadet die Dinger einfach am Ende.
Ja gut.
Ich meine, gehen tut es jetzt so auch.
Ja, also jetzt könnten wir...
Wie war das?
Tokyo Select konnte man noch machen.
Tokyo Select, das ist so was ähnliches.
Da konnte man sagen, genau,
Tokyo Select, du Staff, du More Staff
und das erste, was fertig ist, gewinnt quasi.
Aber ich will ja hier was zurück.
Ne, so genau check ich's
jetzt nicht, wenn man das jetzt gescheit machen würde.
Also in .NET könnte man's mit
einen Cancellation Token machen, dass wir hier
hier canceln, quasi.
So, jetzt kann man das joinen.
Result?
Das hat kein Result.
So, weil das Ding ist,
ich will das hier auch gar nicht joinen.
Aber der Task hier wird ja nie fertig.
Ich will einen Spinner anzeigen, während es downloadet hier.
Also ich meine, was man machen könnte ist, man übergibt den...
übrigens leute sagte mal sagte mal jetzt mal eine blöde frage läuft das hier
jetzt überhaupt parallel an der stelle nee oder
warum ich neuen tags machen will dass das hier im hintergrund den den den
spinner animiert und hier halter download in der zwischenzeit läuft aber
Leute, das läuft, das geht doch
überhaupt nicht parallel.
Wie mache ich jetzt
parallel da die Downloads?
Sekunde, Sekunde, Sekunde.
Das müssen wir jetzt mal checken.
Wenn ich jetzt hier Get Domain Info
mache, machen wir jetzt hier Print.
Hack W.
Oder noch besser.
Das geht
alles nacheinander, ne?
Das geht alles nacheinander.
Nicht alles gleichzeitig.
Alles nacheinander.
Okay, wie...
Dann müssen wir erstmal ran.
Wie sag ich Tokio?
Ach, sag ich vielleicht jetzt so?
Tokio?
Spawn?
So was hier.
Jetzt verstehe ich.
Tokio Spawn.
Anscheinend nicht.
Okay, das ist mir jetzt zu high IQ Rust gerade.
Cannot be sent between threats safely.
Ach.
Warum nicht?
An was liegt es denn?
Okay, das ist jetzt High IQ Shit.
Es ist Async, ja.
Legt das vielleicht...
Legt das am Result-Type?
Produziert aber kein Tokyo.io Result.
Ne, will ich ja auch gar nicht.
Muss es das?
Ist schon so richtig.
Wartet mal, ich habe hier was, wo ich weiß, dass es funktioniert.
Warte mal, wir müssen, wir probieren mal,
wir probieren mal was anderes.
Ich glaube, das liegt, ich glaube, das liegt an diesem
an diesem Return-Type hier.
Da fragen wir jetzt mal.
Okay.
Kann ich das in Tokio verwenden?
Spawn
Implementiert nicht
Send
Aha, Box tun Standard Error, Error has to return time. By default this time is not Thread safe.
es ist nicht cent so so change this line
what what was ist das jetzt jetzt kommt wieder etwas shit
ok
ach jetzt jetzt geht tokio sport
Jetzt geht das, oder wie?
Jetzt bin ich verwirrt.
Weil ich das letzte Mal Overwatch gespielt habe.
Boah, das ist Jahre her.
Das ist Jahre her.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Also Overwatch 2 habe ich nie gespielt.
ich habe so hart auf 1 gegründet sogar esl kaps und somit gespielt aber die
luft ist dann irgendwann raus gewesen und was mich halt übelst abgefuckt hat
bei overwatch ist dass das so lange gedauert hat alles
das hat ja wirklich alles ewig gedauert
So, und jetzt?
Ich wollte das eigentlich nochmal printen.
Alter, wenn man nochmal tippen könnte, ne?
Okay, jetzt wartet er nicht.
So, und jetzt würde ich sagen,
Tokio Join, müssen wir jetzt sagen.
Dass der wartet, bis alles fertig ist.
Tokio Join.
So.
Aha.
Guck, jetzt macht das gleichzeitig alles.
Und wie krieg ich da jetzt aus diesem Result
irgendwas raus?
Also ich will jetzt ja die
Sachen printen gleich.
Unwrap.
Okay.
Was?
Das ist ein...
Das ist ein Topel?
Oder was kommt da zurück?
Hä?
Ja, aber das kann es doch jetzt nicht sein.
Ich brauche eine Schleife
darüber.
Das geht jetzt ohne Spawn?
Aber das läuft jetzt auch.
Jetzt läuft es nicht parallel, oder?
Doch.
Moment, jetzt bin ich verwirrt.
Warum muss ich das jetzt nicht spawnen?
Ach, der kann jetzt
während das auf Netzwerk I.O.
wartet schon das nächste starten.
Oder wie ist das?
Ich brauche gar keine Threads.
Okay.
Ja gut, dann ist so auch okay.
Aber wie kriege ich denn jetzt die Results da raus?
Aber ich kann doch jetzt nicht sowas machen wie Result 1, 2.
Kann man das nicht iteraten?
Aber ich kann doch jetzt nicht...
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Ich kann doch jetzt nicht schreiben 0.blablub.
Ich will eine Schleife da drüber machen.
Geht das nicht?
Rust, iterate, tuppel.
Ich glaube, dafür gibt es...
Okay.
Aha.
Okay, Chat.
Das probieren wir jetzt aus.
Was ist denn da jetzt der Unterschied dazwischen?
Also jetzt.
Ich mach das jetzt mal wie Afterlife,
das da schreibt.
Also ich mach jetzt hier Results.
Das hier mal weg.
Ähm.
tasks gleich Vector und dann let results gleich join all tasks.
Und das benutzt jetzt auch Tokio oder was macht das jetzt?
Das läuft auf jeden Fall auch parallel.
Das benutzt
Futures, die Rust Async Implementierung.
Moment, warum brauche ich dann überhaupt
Tokio und warum ist dann Tokio in jedem
Tutorial drin und
wird überall bloß, wenn Rust selbst schon Async
hat?
Oh man, das ist aber echt teilweise
hardcore verwirrend, man.
Was?
Joinset?
If you have a list of domains, you want to...
Was zum Teufel ist schon wieder Joinset?
Ach, das ist das gleiche!
Das ist das gleiche wie in der Standard Library.
Ein Joint Set.
Set Spawn.
Haha.
Okay, das probiere ich jetzt mal aus.
Wobei das so hier ja auch funktionieren würde.
Results und dann können wir sagen Map.
Result ist dann...
Gut, jetzt muss ich auch unwrappen.
anruppen dann kann ich sagen status machen wir das erst mal so weil dann ist
relativ easy und über überschaubar
also results map
Map?
Results?
Kann ich jetzt sowas sagen wie...
Hä?
Was habe ich jetzt falsch gemacht?
Eben ging es doch auch.
Ach, Ida habe ich vergessen.
Ich kack du.
an rap
ich will das gar nicht ich will jetzt machen
kann ich nicht kann ich nicht sagen fragezeichen
dass es dann direkt return fernsehen fehler gibt doch das geht auch fragen
Das geht anscheinend nicht.
Ja, sowas.
Stimmt, sowas.
Sowas in der Richtung.
Du hast recht.
Sowas will ich.
Wahrscheinlich.
Flat Map.
Okay, macht jetzt was.
Unwrap
Ah, nicht, geh weg
Ich bin zu dumm dafür.
Ich will doch einfach nur
die Results haben, Mann.
Ah, ich glaube, ich weiß, was es ist.
Ich weiß, ich weiß, was es ist.
Das muss klonbar sein.
Und dann kann ich sagen,
Clone.
Fuck! Warum nicht?
Ah, ich darf es nicht
unwrappen.
Nee, nee.
Ich check's nicht.
Alter, wo ist das Problem?
Wonka ist, man.
Hi.
Okay.
Raxe Results
into a Rector.
Rust ist hardcore, was das angeht.
ok also jetzt vor result in results
wie jetzt das ist doch mehr oder weniger das gleiche was ich gerade mit der schleife auch
gemacht habe aber das immer noch kein vector
ist doch noch viel besser
besser
Okay, das funzt aus irgendwelchen gründen jetzt
aus irgendwelchen gründen funktioniert das jetzt
checkt er das nicht selbst von alleine
moment wenn jetzt brauchen wir wieder den den wie ist das ding den spaceship operator
gut okay leute wir haben es domain infos passt theoretisch kann man das übrigens auch so
schreiben dass es noch ein bisschen hässlicher wird können wir nicht annehmen das auch noch
Domaininfos
So und da will ich jetzt eine
Eine Tabelle draus bauen
Data
Im Prinzip einfach
Domaininfo
Äh ok
Achso printen muss ich es noch
Zack
Ja gut
Ok dann
jetzt hier nochmal den ganzen Krempel rein.
Zack.
Evade muss aber weg.
Rustorts.
Was geht eigentlich da gerade im Hintergrund ab?
Okay.
Und jetzt
Easy, guck mal, ist gleich viel schneller. So, jetzt machen wir hier noch das Print hier raus, weil das eigentlich nichts damit zu tun hat.
Sicher, dass es noch Essig ist? Ja.
Geht auch viel schneller wie vorher.
Hast du ja eben an dem Print gesehen, da startet alles zeitgleich und wartet nicht, bis was fertig ist.
Das ist Async.
So.
Gut, das hier gefällt mir immer noch nicht.
Ne, hier kommt ein Future zurück.
Und das wird erst...
Hier werden diese ganzen Dinger gestartet.
Oder werden die hier schon gestartet?
Ne, ne, ne.
Futures in Rust.
Solange sie nicht erwartet werden.
werden nicht gestartet die werden immer nur beim await also hier quasi sowie
mache ich das jetzt wie kriege ich jetzt meinen wie kriege ich das hier ordentlich
pb gibt sowas wie status oder sowas pb status aber was ich jetzt auch nicht
machen kann ist Finish,
weil es ja hier gemovt wurde.
Das wird ja hier
gemovt hier rein. PB.
Kann ich das
vielleicht mit einem...
Wird trotzdem gemovt.
PB 2.
Das kann ja durchaus sein.
Da müssen wir jetzt nämlich hier sagen.
BG join.
Oder.
Await.
Ne, nicht await.
Äh.
Ja doch, das probier ich ja gerade.
Das Outlifters
Wie auch immer das jetzt
Outliften kann
Keine Ahnung
Wir müssen da ein Arc drum herum bauen
Dann wird es funktionieren
Ah, dann würde das funktionieren
Also wir können jetzt quasi sagen, dass das hier ein Arc ist
Ja
Oh
Jetzt PB
Geht immer noch nicht, weil
Ach, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment
Es muss ein Arc Mutex sein, ne?
Achso, das funktioniert
Du hast schon recht
Weil jetzt movt er ja den gesamten Arc
Warte mal, was ist denn jetzt, wenn ich es jetzt nachlebe?
PB2 gleich
Clone
Jetzt funzt's
geht das auch irgendwie schöner als wo ich das jetzt hier gemacht habe
geht das geht das gibt es auch vielleicht noch in schön
moment moment moment das ist ja das ist ja trotzdem eine endlos schleife hier
hängt.
Das ist ja trotzdem...
Das ist ja Blödsinn.
Das ist ja eine Endlosschleife. Ich muss die ja irgendwie canceln.
Hat Tokio...
Tokio Cancellation
Token. Gibt es nicht sowas?
Token New.
Token Clone.
Token Cancelled.
Aha, probieren wir mal aus.
Meine IDE checkt es wieder nicht.
import
cancellation trocken jetzt will ich so was sagen wie loop
Weil
Token
ist cancelled.
Ne, Cloned Token
Boah, ist das abartig, man.
Das kann doch so nicht sein.
Sag ich Token
cancelled.
Okay,
das würde jetzt funktionieren,
Aber es ist doch hardcore eklig, Mann.
Das ist hyper abartig.
Das kann es nicht sein.
Aber ich brauche das hier gar nicht mehr jetzt.
Das brauche ich nicht mehr.
Und das muss auch kein Arc mehr sein.
Weil das kann da ruhig reingemoved werden.
Und jetzt sage ich hier unten nämlich einfach.
Token Cancel.
Zack.
Funst.
listening excellent
listening
ok es funktioniert
und es ist parallel weiß aber da vielleicht hier noch einen nachdem ich das gecancelt habe
Kann man da vielleicht noch ein
Rindlein oder sowas machen danach?
Ah ne, jetzt müsste ich es noch erwarten.
Das ist egal.
Ja doch, jetzt geht's.
Jetzt.
Jetzt müssen wir nämlich hier unten noch sagen.
BB.
Finish.
naja
ist richtig nice
ist nett, aber
ist fast, fast weg
also damit kann ich leben
das ist eigentlich ganz gut so
so, jetzt haben wir ein halbwegs hübsches
Kommandozeilentool
Und jetzt sind wir mal ganz fies
Jetzt gucken wir mal, wie schnell das ist
Mit
Noch ein paar Domains mehr
Geht klar, oder?
Also das ist doch
vollkommen in Ordnung.
Wenn es zwei Sekunden, drei Sekunden
braucht,
für irgendwie, wie viel, ein, zwei, drei,
massig Domains zu checken,
da kann man nichts sagen, oder?
Das ist schon
schon ok.
Nö, da kann ich mitleben.
So, Chat.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Wir wissen, dass Ratatouille suckt
für das, was ich machen wollte.
Wir haben zwei gescheite
Libraries gefunden. Einen für Table, einen für Progress.
Was mich immer noch
ziemlich triggert, dass es da nicht eins
gibt.
Oder dass auch keiner
Rich geportet hat nach Rust.
Außer AI-Slop.
Copy-Paste.
Ich bin begeistert.
chat
mir reicht's für heute mein kopf macht nicht mehr rast mit ich hoffe euch hat es trotzdem
gefallen wenn du nicht gefall hat kann man jetzt gerne voller da lassen geht demnächst
weiter jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt mit rast direkt wir gucken uns demnächst noch die
verbleibenden desktop umgebung bei cash ios an nachdem ich ja kde überraschenderweise ganz gut
fand vier stunden wir haben jetzt vier stunden rust stells gemacht und davon aber bestimmt zwei
stunden versucht mit ratatouille die diese tabelle hinzubekommen was nicht geklappt hat
Ja, Leute.
Dann gehe ich jetzt mal duschen eine Runde.
Und dann Abendessen.
Und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Stream.
Bis dann.
Schön, dass alle mit am Start gewesen sind.
Macht's gut.
See you!